Hmm.
Before we even started the podcast,
rest in peace.
John Anthony West,
he,
uh,
died yesterday.
One of the coolest guys ever.
One of my favorite people that ever got
on the podcast,
the first and only full gas that I've
ever done skype.
And the only reason why I did it on
Skype,
he's cause he wasn't feeling well and he
couldn't fly to California.
So I said,
this guy is so important.
I generally like to have conversations
with people when they're in the room.
I think they go more friendly and
they're smoother.
That way you can work through any bumps
easier.
That way he feel better.
It feels like it's real.
I mean,
but he was so important to me.
I would have fucking taken,
uh,
a raven note.
You know what I mean?
He just,
if you'd never seen,
um,
the DVD series,
magical Egypt,
it's truly an amazing piece of work.
Um,
it's,
I think six dvds all about the history
of Egypt and the immense complexity of
the structures that are built there.
The appreciation this guy had for what
the Egyptians did was just off the
charts.
He was just so deeply engaged with it.
It was such a giant part of his life and
the passion and the curiosity that they
had in the knowledge that he had.
And these dvds would come through and
you would just be like holding your face
watch.
And I'm going,
all my God,
these are amazing.
Just what a crazy time in human history,
this weird blip in the middle of North
Africa where these people just went past
everybody else just way past.
And they did it for a long time.
Man.
They did it in this one spot for who
knows how long.
That's where it was.
Thousands and thousands of years.
And Graham Hancock and John Anthony West
are the people that are really,
uh,
at the front of the line in terms of the
public eye of pushing the timeline back
and there's real evidence for it.
Yeah,
sure.
I mean,
hancock's getting super vindicated or,
yes,
he is.
And you know,
um,
John Anthony West had vindicated as well
by um,
uh,
Robert Schoch,
who's a geologist from Boston
University.
He went to Egypt and he studied the
enclosure that the Sphinx was in and
he's the guy that determined that you
were looking at fishers that were
created by thousands of years of
rainfall,
which would push back because what we
know about the,
the what the climate was like in that
area.
Apparently it pushes it back to
somewhere around 9,000
years ago,
which is crazy.
Yeah.
Cause look however old it was,
it's real.
The pyramids are a real thing.
Sure.
I mean everybody gets real weird about
pushing the date back.
Like when it happened.
There's no way it happened 30,000
years ago.
It definitely happened.
2,500
BC maybe.
Maybe,
but it'd be,
even if it did,
let's just say it all was,
it just came out of nowhere.
Some are around that Arrow.
What a crazy spot,
man.
I mean forget about the,
the,
the confusion and the conflict around
the timeline.
Just what it is.
Those people were on another level.
What is the main reason people get so
pissed off at Hancock and West for
trying to push the timeline back?
Because they'd been teaching one
timeline for a long time.
They don't want to admit they were
wrong.
If somebody publishes a book about the
timeline and just say definitively says,
we know now that Egypt was a,
you know,
hunter gatherer culture that somewhere
around 3000 BC erupted into this
incredible civilization.
Right?
They just been teaching that for so
long.
I mean,
there've been teaching,
uh,
not that version of it,
but there were,
their version is more accurate than what
I just said.
I'll just making up numbers.
But the point is,
what they've been teaching is probably
not right.
And if they wrote books about it,
they've t taught classes about it.
All these people,
it's ego.
It's just the ego of scientists.
There is 100% some ego involved because
there was a conversation that John
Anthony West and doctor Robert Schoch
had with an egyptologist and the
Egyptologist.
This is on a television show that was
actually on TV.
It was on like NBC.
It was called the mystery.
That's finks.
It was actually narrated by Charlton
Heston and,
uh,
it was all about John Anthony West work
and about Graham Hancock's work and
Robert shocks work.
And,
um,
when they brought this geological
evidence to these egyptologists,
they were openly mocking it,
like laughing in this weird way.
What evidence is there for this
civilization back then?
Like how much evidence do you think
would be there?
Like you have to realize how long ago
he's talking about,
he's talking about maybe 10,000,
500 BC,
maybe earlier.
They think it might have all started
somewhere around 30,000
years ago,
which is just fucking bananas.
Oh,
there it is.
Mystery.
This famous powerful Jamie finds it
online are they are John Anthony West
that he,
um,
litter literally dedicated his life to
absorbing as much information as
possible about the nature of the
construction,
the time periods,
the hieroglyphs.
I mean,
it's just an amazing,
amazing body of work that that guy put
together.
Powerful.
Charlton Heston look eager that I can
answer.
I would hang out with him.
I don't care.
Even if he was wacky,
we wanted to talk about guns all day.
I'd be like,
come on Charles and hang out with
Charlton Heston was going to turn down.
Charles,
do you remember when Charleston has
another gun on TV and it was like
they'll take my rifle away when they pry
my cold dead hands off of it.
Did he hold up a rifle when he said
that?
I imagine.
I don't know man.
I think he probably did.
I so not.
Why not?
Why not hold up your fucking massive
symbol for your cock,
your Harry Potter?
He said it.
It's real.
It's just as I imagined.
He will never take my cock for me.
It's even better because it's a musket.
Why not just hold up a rock just like
got rock any rock,
huh?
Yeah.
People get fucking really passionate
about that.
That guns circumcision.
I am.
Oh,
I am all for responsible people being
able to own guns,
but I'm also completely in agreement
with people that say that there's too
many people out there committing crimes
with guns.
So how do you,
how do you,
how do you clean all that up?
I do not know.
Well,
it's worth thinking about.
It is worth thinking about and it's
worth talking about.
And people get upset when you start
talking about it because they want it to
be just know we have a right to have any
kind of gun that we want,
but they're,
I think they're missing.
Um,
one of the real big problems,
which were just weirdly seeing the very
beginning of it,
dude.
And this ties in,
you know,
like Elon Musk just blasted the fucking
car and his face.
He blessed the Tesla,
the space.
There's a tesla floating around the
planet now.
And like the,
the way that connects with guns is,
um,
this is an example of technology falling
into the hands of like a private
company.
This isn't the government.
This is like Ilan fucking bad ass.
I go to burning man musk,
a dude who goes to burning man,
shot a fucking tesla into space,
which is now,
I guess going to rotate around the
planet for some certain,
I don't know how long it's going to be
up there.
Well,
I think it's going to Mars.
Oh,
that fucking thing is going on.
Put it in orbit around Mars.
It's going past Mars.
Oh,
you fucked up he lawn.
Well guess what man,
that could have been my mom.
My mom can fill on that plane.
You fucking asshole.
You fucked up.
Ilan.
You could have done better dumb dumb
with your rockets that can land and
shooting a gun in his face.
Okay,
what?
That is what happened.
It's when you take it out of the
government's hands and put it in a
geniuses hands,
but he's got a very unique ability to
get things done.
Sure.
That boring project that he's doing
under La flame throwers,
there's certain guys that are so smart
that everybody goes cause okay,
sure.
Everybody has steps back and go,
what do I do?
Want to dig holes through the bottom.
Beth,
what else do you went to the La City
Council meeting?
It's like,
look guys,
I can fix this traffic thing.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to
drill holes underneath the ground and
I'm going to put your car on a high
speed sled and
you don't even drive this.
It's like,
okay guys.
So,
uh,
you've been,
you remember the old like how it used to
be at the banks with the suction tubes.
Where are you taking a tube and you,
your mom puts the check in and it gets
sucked in.
I'm going to do that with fucking buses
under the city.
What do you think?
Write the check.
They're not going to let you do it.
But the thing where it connects to guns
is it's like we're looking at the very,
very,
very beginning of of private individuals
having access to technology that
normally it was in the hands of the
state governments.
And this is the very crazy beginning of
it.
I didn't know he was shooting at,
at Mars for some reason.
I thought that fucking thing was going
to like rotate around the earth,
which made me worry that like we're
going to end up with like a ring of
billionaire car cause he'll be like the
coolest thing for billionaires to do.
Shoot your car up.
It's also a great way to dispose a
body's cause.
Like there's that astronaut in there and
I keep thinking like,
I bet that's one of the Elon Musk's
enemies.
I bet he that could be a body in there
and no one would ever fucking magic of
it is just some asshole who robbed Elan
Musk in a business deal.
Yeah,
just shot the guy and have one of his
flunky stuff.
I'm into a car you never fight.
Just disappeared.
He just disappeared.
That can be fucking anybody man.
Control to major Tom and then also
what's really bad as about this is the
flat earthers are now like really having
problems because of the,
somebody sent me a video today,
show me that it's fake.
The building on twitter so many that
this is fake.
It's fake.
Brown was frank bro.
What is that?
What's fake up like what's the thing?
The moon,
the sky.
The God of the car.
Your mom is flat,
fake,
fake.
Fake.
Your mom's flat as fuck man.
Your mom's flouted in the plant earth
Bro.
And the earth's flat.
But is it this like the,
the,
what's crazy about the John Anthony West
stuff and the Graham Hancock stuff is
like in the way that flat earth and
delusional insane way sort of forces you
to imagine yourself existing in a
universe that's completely different
than what you thought.
And I think that's why it's really
appealing.
Like it's an appealing cool,
beautiful,
hilarious mythology was just like,
whoa,
how cool would that be if we really were
on a flat earth?
And like if I just keep going in one
direction and hit the ice wall,
hit the ice well,
but over the fucking ice,
well now we're in the land of the grays,
you know,
I'm no longer trapped.
It's like,
it's a freeing feeling because like,
even though it's not like I travel
enough to feel stuck in fucking
California,
which is an insane thing,
there's a little piece of us that knows
we're never going to go into space.
We're never going to get past.
We're never going to,
how do you get off the map?
You know what I mean?
Like there's something in a human that
wants to get off the fucking map where
you end up in a place that hasn't been
charted yet and that's an experience
that's gone basically like the,
I mean I imagine swaths of the Amazon
perhaps or like some place deep deep in
the Arctic may be in a cave or
something,
but it used to be people just didn't
fucking know you could go off the map
and you had no idea.
I think that must have been the biggest
rush to be on a ship and looking at the
maps that you guys have and you're like,
fuck dude,
this is,
we don't know where we're at here man.
Like this is unknown uncharted terrain.
So flat earth is a really,
I'm not,
I don't believe the earth is flat.
I it's more like a triangle shape.
But the other guy,
it's a big Dick.
It's a giant cosmic dick at that would
be looking at the head of the Dick and
they just don't want us to know that
cause it's kind of embarrassing.
Fucking earth looks like a big spinning
Dick.
It's all CGI,
bro.
Shaped like a dick.
It's just a big blue and white fucking
Dick Green.
Yeah.
Why do people want that?
We want,
we always want things to be weird,
right?
We want,
look,
the flat earth one is my favorite one
because it's just,
what could you imagine if their rights q
magic they were writing,
but I if the whole plant,
I thought the world was round and
there's all this information that shows
the world is round.
For thousands of years ago people were
doing calculations are sticking sticks
into the ground in equal distance and
measuring them and trying to see if
there's curvature and the this Zoe's
been people that suspected the earth was
round way before they could ever figure
it out.
They were trying to sell it.
Look well the moon is round,
the sun is round.
This is around.
Oh yeah,
probably this was round.
Yeah.
And how much she would kind of think,
well how big is this fucking thing?
And then if you get up high enough you
can kind of see like wow,
if it's this really big,
I see like a very slight curvature.
I can,
maybe I do.
Am I always on my mind?
Fucking myself.
Right.
And you could just sat around and mind
fucked yourself into thinking that it
was all a scam.
Yeah.
And that the world is actually flat and
then gravity isn't real either.
Everybody's wrong.
Yeah.
Except but guy on youtube,
it's exciting.
It's magnets that pull people into the
earth.
Your life gets so exciting at that
point.
Oh yes.
Now you are.
You're,
you feel danger.
You're risking your fucking ass by
getting out there.
Cause the Nass holes are going to take
you out.
Dude,
the Clinton Foundation,
Clinton Foundation finds out about your
theories.
The earth being flat.
You're fuck,
come get you.
They're going to get you.
So now you're living,
now you get to live in maybe a not very
happy world,
but an exciting world because you're
seeing vans,
you're seeing fucking like create.
Now this is,
by the way,
this is not say that there isn't some
massive,
huge unknown swath of reality that's
sitting right in front of us at all
times.
It's actively being hidden by the United
States government in the military.
That the technology that they finally
detected the thing and they don't want
us to know because they know if we know
who the fuck knows what the reason is,
but they don't want us to know just yet.
I'm not saying that's not the case.
I'm just saying with flat earth in
particular.
Freaking me the fuck out man.
What do you know?
What do I know?
What do you know man?
The fucking problem is I can't talk
about it yet.
Oh my,
I stopped getting the check.
They're like,
you can't like,
you know,
we'll tell you but you can't,
you can't completely reveal.
It seems like one of the videos that
would play before you,
uh,
first loading up halflife 10,
this is the new new half life.
The government is hiding a dimension.
Well,
I may have access to just come out was
that they picked up some kind of Ufo
like the government did release Ufo
video.
I always assume this is captain
skeptical over here.
I always assume if the government is
ever sang that there's Ufo shows or
something really crazy like that,
it's to hide some shit they're doing in
like Guatemala.
It's like they don't want anybody to be
paying attention to something weird
they're doing so they'll,
they'll just start talking about u of o
is everybody's art for real,
like a real special,
you've got a video man.
I mean it's a really huge question mark,
which is,
and there are people out there who like
think,
who say they have answers to why they're
just this idea is there is a gradual
dissemination of information that's
happening because they're,
they're priming the pump and then it
splits into two versions.
One of the versions of the stories is,
fuck,
if you want to dominate a planet,
get them kind of like subconsciously,
subliminally primed for the idea that
you know,
I think there's some really advanced
technology out there and there's,
there's aliens riding around in it and
we've,
and we make contact,
we've made contact with a,
they call themselves the Galactic
Council of Celestial elders and they've
been making contact with us for the last
50 years and they've been instructing us
and how to not only reveal themselves to
you,
but to,
to let the technology come out in a way
that's not going to be completely
catastrophic for our society.
There are peace loving,
wonderful beings,
but we've decided to follow their
instructions to the t and so now they're
ready to introduce themselves and then
suddenly an alien is on TV and suddenly
the government is using a completely
made up thing to try to dominate the
planet by saying,
no,
it's aliens.
We found them when in fact it's project
blue beam.
Right.
That's,
that's one of the ideas that are their
ideas.
All that Shit's true.
They,
there's a thing that happens when a
planet reaches a certain level of
technological sophistication that it
gets contacted by some kind of order
council federation of Cindy and
technological civilizations and they
sort of begin to like walk the planet
through phases of getting that shit out
into the world in a way that isn't going
to fuck up their planet and they know
how to do it.
They have a system in place,
they don't come from the stars.
They're not something detectable by
telescopes there.
Like in the DMT realm,
are there like existing in some
alternate dimension and technology is
just one of the things that they,
uh,
use to communicate with us.
I've
been toying around with this idea for a
long time.
Most of the time when I'm really high,
that ideas are a life form that they're
not,
it's not as simple as your creativity,
putting together some pieces that
weren't there before.
I think it's that,
but I think it's you're
tuning into something,
you're tuning into some weird,
like some of the ideas almost seem to
write themselves and it could be because
the subconscious process of your mind,
but it also could because the,
because that these what ideas are and
what just the concept of thinking is
it's essentially the seeds of creation,
right?
Everything that's ever existed on earth,
the humans have invented and built came
from a mind.
It came from thinking,
how do I put together this house?
Yeah,
how do I put together this skyscraper?
How do I make a plane?
How do I make a TV?
How do I make of this?
How do I make of that?
Like we're vessels for ideas.
We're like sitting there with all these
neurons firing and electricity going
left and right,
and all these areas of our brains
lighting up.
It's catching ideas.
When I'm super gone,
especially on edibles,
sometimes I feel like I'm in a river of
ideas and I'm naked and I can't hold the
fish that just flying by me.
I'm like,
Jesus,
just trying to get these ideas right.
It almost feels like these are not at my
ideas.
These are ideas that I'm working on.
I've put in the effort to go out and
fish for these ideas.
Well it's kind of like imagine if there
was a technology that could,
like we send out these signals into
space,
um,
satellites with er,
with,
with fucking records in them,
but perhaps other civilizations are
blasting the planet with ideas,
Eh,
that are designed to be picked up by the
scope of the human mind.
Yeah.
And so what you're doing is you're
actually like popping into an alien
frequency which is filled with all these
various ideas that are part of the
cultivation of a planet to like try to
get it to the point of like being able
to make contact and they're,
they're just seeding,
seeding us with,
with fuck.
When you read like John Lilly and read
about Tesla and read about a lot of the
great inventions that have happened,
the people who had the epiphanous
moment,
it wasn't like there was scrunching
their fucking forehead.
It was like the idea came to them and a
vision.
How many times do you hear over and over
again?
It came to me in a vision,
a dream.
Do you know that the very notion of
science itself,
uh,
came to supposedly like the birth of
science came from a dream that day cards
had really,
yeah.
He had a dream that,
I forget exactly the term that he,
the way they use it,
I'm sure it was deciphered too,
right?
Like what did he originally speak?
What language to car descartes speak?
Fuck,
I don't know man.
Like I think it was like classic Nerd,
but he was,
um,
he was out like at war,
who's like campaigning.
He is French,
he's French.
He was a,
I believe it was like he was on a
military campaign in the army or
something along those lines.
And uh,
he signed up for adventure to go off
into the military.
And during that time period he had a
dream that something about to be able to
harness nature,
it would be done in weights and
measurements.
I forget exactly the term,
see if he could find the term.
The,
that was essentially what people say.
This is really when you,
when you talk about the very birth of
the early,
so you could trace back the idea of
modern science,
like the ethics and the ideas,
the concepts of Mondo Science.
Well don't you from a dream don't date
it goes,
I mean before the cart we're dealing
with like it gets really interesting
because you're dealing with that
outcome.
It's like John d who were,
who were,
I mean Jon Dee was someone who is,
who's John d?
John D is,
is it like,
you know Jason Lu,
you know that is,
no,
he's an author.
He just wrote this fucking bad ass book
on John D.
Is this one of those people kind kinda
like Crawley who had this huge impact on
society but we don't really know a lot.
We would,
most people don't know the fuck he was.
Right.
But you've heard of like,
uh,
the Enoki and tablets are like the
Gnocchi and angels basically.
John Dee was like an outcome as to is
working with Queen Elizabeth to try to
turn lead into gold,
which was a,
you know,
a big fucking pursuit back then,
which is like,
shit,
if we could turn,
if we can transmute metals into gold,
it's like,
I mean they all tried to yeah,
do that,
right?
Was that when they first started
recognizing elements?
Like when did they first start
Um,
I,
I don't,
I don't know probably that it's,
it must be through alchemy cause they
were like trying to break things down to
their fundamental,
they're trying to break things down to
like their fundamental components.
How many movies are about that?
Someone trying to make gold?
Well,
I mean it's the,
it's one of the great pursuits and it's
actually,
that's that there's a,
it's what we're still doing only we're
not trying to turn a lead into gold.
We're trying to turn a lead into a
thinking machine.
That's what we're doing that because
better than turning matter and to goal,
if you can turn matter and do a fucking
thing that is thinking and cindy hunt
the nic and figure out how to turn lead
into gold by its advanced ability to
process data.
And if you were an alien race,
you'd be concerned about nuclear weapons
for sure,
but you would really be concerned about
artificial life.
Sure.
What do you,
what do you assholes about to hit the
switch on?
Yeah.
Have you thought this?
This through would like those minions in
despicable me.
We're just wrecking shit and eaten
nails,
right?
Yeah.
We just try and things stick in
electrical sockets in our heads.
Fuck yeah.
Dude.
Can you imagine if beings in the DMT
Rome decided to start setting off
nuclear explosions?
I mean,
maybe that's what an earthquake is.
Maybe when we have an earthquake,
it's like a nuclear test and another
dimension shaking our planet.
Yeah,
I said it.
No,
I don't fucking believe it.
I can already hear the light people
being like,
what the fuck are you talking about,
man?
June 8th,
1637 day card cut codifies scientific
method.
Wow.
Interesting.
He outlines his rules for understanding
the natural world through reason and
skepticism,
forming the foundation of the scientific
method still in use today.
There a a term that he had that he came
up with like in a dream,
see if he could find that because there
was like a phrase that he said obviously
translated from French.
I,
I the reason I s the dit cart fucking
bugs before him,
that one.
No,
it's not.
I think therefore I am.
Okay.
But that was obviously an interesting
one.
He liked to do shit like,
and I could be wrong about this,
but I,
I clearly remember reading about this.
He was like,
what do you call it mechanistically or
like he believed the animals were just
machines basically.
And so,
so like he would like,
and I love Jamie if you could look this
up.
So I don't get a suede with people being
like,
that's a different person.
But apparently he would do shit like
hold that dog's beating heart and it's
in his hand while it died.
Oh my God.
And he said things like,
people who are afraid to kick dogs
aren't really my students because they
know it will look that up,
Jamie.
We share this,
not like propaganda.
If there was like an info wars.com
back then like what's going on here?
This is why I'm covering it with like,
I'm not saying he's out there kicking
dogs.
I think he was kicking dogs.
I think the cart like I just found it
was pretty rough.
Maybe they all kick dogs back then.
In a nutshell,
frank fro philosopher Rene decartes
didn't believe animals had souls to test
his theory.
Nailed his wife's dog to a board and
chopped it open while the poor thing was
still a long guy.
Fun Guy.
Crater is science was a nail and dogs to
fucking boards.
Where'd you read this?
How do we know it's on fucking hard.com?
No,
it's nuts.
It's nuts.
I hope that you really are knowledge,
nuts,
nuts for knowledge.
I love nuts.
That guy definitely looks like he
fucking Nail Dogs to boards.
Look at that fucking face.
Mm,
mm.
Look at it.
Squirm.
The greatest minds are capable of the
greatest vices as well as the greatest
virtues.
That's what he said after cut open a
cat,
dude,
that's like,
it's the father of science is also like,
that's Jeffrey Dahmer Level Shit too.
Like he was not,
I think people did a lot of that back
then.
Nayland dogs divorce.
I just think the,
I think the value of life was severely
diminished.
I think back then the 16 hundreds people
were dying left and right of everything.
You got a cold dead break your leg dead,
get gored by a bull,
dead,
everything dead.
Oh,
you got an infection dead.
Well you got the flu,
probably dead.
But
that's definitely in Europe.
Like in India.
I'm not saying in India it was like a
utopia and everyone is sweet to animals,
but in Buddhism it was still,
it was like there was,
it was a lot more compassionate.
Like that's true.
Why do you think that happened?
APP
and why does like like Thailand and
places that are Buddhist places
generally?
I mean obviously there's violence
everywhere,
but generally more of a peaceful vibe.
Right?
Like Buddhist nations and Buddhist
crying a little bit.
Obviously flaws with everything.
Yes.
Anything involving people you're going
to have outliers but over and all.
Like one of the things that my friend
was telling me about Thailand,
he was like,
dude,
there's no crime over there.
He's like,
you just go over there.
He's like everybody.
It's like real easy,
real easy to get along with everybody.
It's like it's super safe.
Nobody gets robbed was it's really rare.
Yeah,
I don't,
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't understand why that way of
thinking emerged in the east and that
connection with the south emerged in the
east first,
what happened in the west,
which was basically decimation of a
previous religion,
right?
Paganism,
whatever you want to call it.
Earth based religion,
connection with life and nature,
but what's really interesting.
Yeah,
tell me about that.
Is it the DNA of paganism is still in
the system?
It's almost like we absorbed it.
Yeah.
Like I say,
we,
I mean Christians,
you know,
Christian nation.
Well,
look,
it's work Christian nation.
This is,
I'm sorry.
I'm sure we've talked about this in the
podcast,
but it's something I marvel over all the
time.
I think about it a lot,
which is the Catholic mass.
It's when you look at the Catholic mass
and you look at the New Testament,
the last supper,
and you look at,
you realize like in the fucking synoptic
gospels and then any of the gospels,
there is nowhere that Jesus is saying.
What you do is take a piece of bread and
utter these prayers over it to create
it,
to create my flash that didn't you eat,
it's not there.
The ritual isn't there and but,
but the interpretation of that has
turned into what is called high magic.
It's called like,
it's a ceremonial magic where you are
transforming bread into the flesh of a
sacrificed God and people do that every
fucking Sunday and are like this totally
normal magic.
What are you talking about?
I'm not in a fucking magic.
What I do is I eat the flesh of a god
that was sacrificed by Father God so
that my sins could be purified.
That's not magic.
When did that originate the sacrament?
Well,
I've read that it has something to do
with,
it goes back to Egypt,
that it,
that it's some kind of high magic
Egyptian ritual mushroom or as a
mushroom
probably had a big bag of mushrooms and
everybody came up and they put it on
your tongue and they said,
good luck.
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
This is the place he on the other side.
I mean they said,
yeah,
they said,
um,
you know,
this is the flesh of God.
Eat this to,
and you'll remember who you truly are
and they gave you this,
the psychedelic and you took it and you
merged back into the divine and realize
your true identity so that for the rest
of the week you were able to hang out
with people and not be a complete ass
hole.
Cause you know,
you share the same soul and that you're
basically made of love as opposed to
thinking that you and I are separate and
that
were mostly sinful,
evil things.
Who's flashes impure?
I mean that's another fucking sweet gift
that came from um,
fundamentalist Christianity is the
concept that our bodies are evil.
We can't be naked around each other.
Even now.
Like you can't take your clothes off
around people without seeming completely
insane.
You will get a wreck if you go outside
and your fundamental body that you are
born into the universe with,
you will get arrested.
Like you can't walk around as you are,
you have to cover it in clothes or if
you're considered to be a fucking
pervert,
nudist,
psycho.
So yeah,
the,
the fundamental vehicle that we are so
rides around and it's considered profane
to,
to do dude.
And it like,
you see a fucking deck when you're like
walking down the street.
Some dudes you're like,
well you can see a dick accidentally at
the bathroom and it doesn't bother,
doesn't bother you.
Cause in the bathroom it's okay for a
moment to profane the world with your
fucking Dick.
So it's like that's the,
when you start really looking at all
the,
the traces of not just pagan culture,
but just insanity from a fundamentalist
perspective of the universe that has its
roots in what appears to be a
misunderstanding of a really beautiful
story.
Then it's like mind boggling.
No,
not just a misunderstanding,
but probably a conscious
misrepresentation of the original store
that's molded the suit.
Whoever's needs is in charge at the
moment.
That's right.
Yeah.
And people do,
I'll tell you,
man,
Catholics,
they feel guilty like they should.
I'm Catholic.
You're filling.
You still probably feel a little bit,
probably a little bit,
dude.
I was thinking,
I'm not Catholic really,
but I was,
when I was in first grade,
I have this allister Croley poster.
I was going to bring the uterus seven Oh
wow.
1079 yeah.
Yeah.
It was the year.
The year 1000 that's it sounds like it's
a weird sounding name.
Oh,
a year.
Other 1079 it feels like I'm saying
something wrong.
Yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
That's amazing,
man.
Yeah,
1079 so this is way after Jesus almost a
thousand years.
Yeah.
They started doing the magical ritual
and and so it's like to say that this is
connected to Christianity is really,
it's like actually no,
it's Christianity's a song and this is a
dance people decided to do to it,
but to say,
you know what I mean?
To say that it's like that it has
anything to do with Jesus is,
is not true unless you're going to say
that Jesus transmitted the data after
his death and do some kind of mistake or
see,
or who had the vision of this.
Now I'm not knocking the fucking
Catholic mass.
I think it's beautiful,
but let's just admit what it is.
Magic.
It's ritual magic.
You're doing ritual magic and you're
doing something that's been going on for
a very long,
probably before 1079
that dude wasn't just like sitting
around.
I'm like,
Hey,
I got an idea.
Let's start saying prayer over the bread
and the bread is going to turn into
flesh.
It was more like,
hey,
you know,
we've been meeting doing these rituals
secretly.
Why don't we just incorporate the story
of Christianity into this ritual that
we've been doing for a very long time.
Do you sort of,
um,
pure,
purify ourselves by connecting to the
universe and acknowledging the fact that
existence itself is predicated on
devouring the flash of some other being
not,
you know,
like we're always in the process of
inhaling the universe,
exhaling the universe eating each other
in the universe is eating itself.
And so the mass is this ritualized
version of like,
behold,
we're eating the flesh of God in
everything we do.
And there's something really beautiful
about that.
I mean,
there's no getting around life eats
life.
Even the various factions of,
of uh,
people on the left and the right and,
uh,
people that are animal rights activists
versus people that are butchers.
You're all eating something that's
alive.
I mean,
you can make the distinction that the
plants aren't suffering like the animals
do.
And that's why it's okay.
Sure.
I agree with you.
For the most part,
it's probably a less extreme form of
suffering,
but it also might just be a completely
misunderstood life form like there.
Well they're finding out so much about
plant communication and I've read so
many things about that.
I hesitate to talk about it cause I
really want to have all my t's sliced
and i's dotted because it's such a
complex issue,
but it appears that they communicate.
It appears that there's almost like a,
that they're using the soil and the
fungus in the soil and the mycelium,
they all have this weird ecosystem.
It's not just like one plant by itself
in the dirt.
You know,
there's a network that they're connected
to.
Did Jamie,
there's this thing,
I've just,
this guy gave me this thing called a
middy sprout,
which is,
it picks up,
I guess the bioelectricity of plants or
anything for that matter.
But plants I've,
I've got it.
You stick it on your plant and it goes
into like your,
whatever your music system is and it
translates it into Midi so you can turn,
turn,
turn the electricity of your plant and a
music.
Yeah,
it's fucking cool.
Yeah.
That sound is the sound's coming from a
tree.
Well,
it's the electricity of the tree being
translated in a middy,
which is then being translated into
sound.
So it's,
it's a way to convert that data into
music.
It's like you're converting the bio
electricity into,
it's not like that's the sound of a
plant.
It's not making celestial noises.
That's just sending energy and creating
mini,
which is then being translated into the
sound.
So it's a way to observe the data
instead of looking at it,
I guess on an Oscilloscope or whatever,
you would look at that with.
Yeah,
it's turning into,
into
uh,
and the audio so you can hear the
pulsating kind of like rhythmic flow so
that it's measuring electrical currents
in the plant.
That's,
so there's that much of a variation that
it's like going up and down all the time
like that.
Yeah.
It,
I mean,
I don't know that the total math behind
it,
but I've got one on my,
I'm on a plan in my studio.
Here's my take on it.
The most potent psychedelic experience
is dmt.
DMT exists in so many different plants.
It's in thousands of plants.
They have,
they have no idea why,
but it's in them.
And if it wasn't for Mano,
Amy's Mano,
Amy's Oxidase,
monoamine oxidase Mao,
which is what Mao inhibitors are.
If it wasn't for that,
that we have this in our body,
we would be tripping on salad.
He'd be tripping on grass.
You eat certain grasses,
you'd be blasted off to the center of
the universe.
You know,
for some sheep,
DMT is poisoned.
Like they get ahold of,
of plants that have DNP even they fall
over,
has the legs and the legs start bucking
up in the air.
That's like a canary in the coal mine.
He takes sheep out into nature and when
they start dying,
that's what you eat.
I think it's [inaudible] grass in
particular.
I think there's a type of grass.
Jamie's if you could find that grass
that kill sheep,
but it's a grass.
A particularly rich.
Yeah.
Florist.
Damn.
How good's the memory on the kid even
though he's,
Hi Phillip Morris back.
Yeah.
That a flare induced Valera staggers and
chief portions of the lower brain as
seen to be damaged and oddly enough,
tinted blue.
They're responsible agents or the
alkaloids contained in the various
failing species.
There are whispered rumors that can you,
there are whispered fucking,
that's a dmt website to that whispered
rumors.
He's got a science not looking for wispy
are whispers,
whispered rumors,
fucking hippies.
The divine moment of truth is that the
one that I'm in is one of those spangled
made one where they use the a rant of me
with Jim Brewer.
That's cool.
I was harp acute.
I barely remember what I said,
but as me and brewer,
uh,
we're high on pot lollipops or Jesus and
they took that and took part of it and
made it this really dope music end with
a video to it.
I don't know if that's their video,
if they made that video.
It does.
It looks oddly similar.
Like a tone down,
like a pencil drawing of what you see
when you do dmt and then,
yeah.
That's a sound.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
I the good old day time.
Joe.
Weren't those the good old days.
Now we don't do it anymore though.
Cause it's elite.
Yeah.
Why would we,
well,
it's illegal.
There's no need.
And also once you've been there,
it's not like you have to keep going
back just enough now Santa,
I need these fucking,
hey,
I need to do right now.
Get a better accountant.
You know what I'm saying?
That's right.
And I,
there's some fucking great accountants
in the DMT realm.
That's when I'll start doing right.
They're accountants of your
consciousness and they look at,
you can go on.
No,
no.
It's the best.
Yeah.
That's pretty not too,
did you get a finger wagging at you?
Yeah.
No.
And it was like when I had a wacky
thought,
I had a bad thought,
a thought when a rag that was on the
wrong page.
I was like,
this isn't an that's cool.
Yeah.
I love that.
I love the in different psychedelic
states.
I love how you witnessed how your
consciousness is forming your reality
and the most extreme way.
Yeah.
Not as though like you're producing
matter with your thoughts or anything
like that,
but you can watch this undulation or
this flow going from when you're getting
negative and dark.
And it's interesting how different
psychedelics portray this phenomena.
But so like on acid you,
I might see,
depending if I'm taking a high enough
dose,
you start seeing like the faces and the
in the Stucco of your ceiling,
you know?
And it's like when you start getting
really depressive or scared,
then the phases start doing like
oh
his thing at you and they seek in and
they,
or even when you're looking at yourself
in the mirror you,
the a similar things happens is you're
just watching the way that your
projection that's coming from the
incessant flow of thoughts in your mind
is reflecting on the reality itself.
And it's a constant like shifting of
light that sometimes is like looking
into the deepest layers of hell.
But then sometimes you see the most
beautiful,
sweet,
incredible things because your not being
freaked out by the flow of thoughts in
your mind.
That's the number one trick.
You know,
this is why now my old age,
I really do understand why I'm a good
practice,
meditation,
chanting,
whatever.
It may be pair so nicely with
psychedelics.
Yeah.
Cause if you have one without the other,
well you're missing out.
But also your,
you can really like go into some pretty
terrifying places that you'd,
that don't resolve in the way that they
could potentially if you are doing the
work,
putting in the time before you take the
Psychedelic,
you know,
not to sound like an old fucking guy
like guy you got to,
you do,
you know,
meditate and then too,
but it does help a lot.
Well it,
it's,
there's a weird way that we,
we want to dismiss it because it seems
almost like a pompous thing to ever say.
You meditate or you encourage people to
meds.
Yeah.
Like the same as I always have a cringy
thing when I tell people to do yoga.
Like am I going have to say this again?
What I really mean it.
Like I feel like yoga is one of the very
best things that will pair with a
cannabis use and with psychedelic.
Sure.
Cause I think it,
it alleviates a lot.
You know,
another thing is really good is running
and I think both those things,
they alleviate a certain amount of
anxiety and they create,
uh,
they,
there's a blood through that.
Like when you're really pumping hard up
a hill and you're running the huffing
and puffing and you make it and you
check your pulse and you recover quick
and he'd go and do another hill run,
there's a,
there's a stimulation of your body
because it's being forced to work hard,
that's euphoric and after it's over,
your brain's flooded with all these
wonderful chemicals.
You feel good,
you feel friendly.
And like I think that paired with
psychedelic experiences,
I think exercise is one of the most
overlooked,
so important.
And it doesn't matter what style,
like what you enjoy doing,
but just got to get that blood going.
You got to do something.
Whether it's take a spin class or a yoga
class or go for a good hike,
do something where you're fucking
huffing and puffing and you're really
getting in some work,
you're really sweating and your body
will just feel
better.
Well,
this is what you just said exactly
applies to meditation and also you're
fucking right.
The problem with even talking about it
is you sound virtue signally and pompous
and it sends it.
But,
but it's true.
And when you hear Ron doss talk about
meditation,
he will say,
I don't meditate when you want to
meditate.
Like don't,
don't even like if it seems like
something that appeals to you,
give it a shot.
But the,
the,
the definition of it,
it's sat.
What's funny is when you think about
meditation,
your mind will summon up something that
you think meditation looks like.
So you think,
I mean it's like sitting down on a
cushion with some fucking candles or it
means like whatever it is that your mind
summons up.
And usually it's pretty austere and
usually it's pretty requires like a
temple or a space in your house or it's
in south and I'll phone you need a robe.
Exactly.
He needs some kind of like shit that
you're wearing,
right?
Because your mind is trying to push it
off.
It's trying to like your mind.
It W it was as one of its functions.
It seems to like not want you to sit
still for a moment and watch.
But what you just said about exercising,
it's true for meditation.
It's like there's so many different
versions of it.
And I would argue running is a
meditation.
Working out is a meditation.
Yeah.
And that to think that it's,
there's a separation there.
There really isn't.
No,
I don't think there was either.
I always just said that about martial
arts.
I believe that martial arts were a
moving form of meditation,
but that doesn't mean like stationary
meditation isn't different and give you
a,
another very valuable thing and a
different,
a different valuable stuff.
Yeah.
Well it gives you the ability to,
I was just reading,
there's a great book I'm reading by Pema
Chodron called the wisdom and no escape.
And uh,
she talks about how when people start
meditating they think,
I'm,
I'm doing this because I want to be a
better person.
And she said,
that's actually an aggression against
the south that you are right now to be
like,
Ooh.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
That you're actually being like
aggressive to your own self.
She said meditation is not so that we
become a better it
so that we're able to be who we are and
the moment fully and to begin to
experience fully what it is that's
happening inside of us because for a lot
of people what's going down is that
there is a dude,
this reminds me,
I just watched the Texas fucking
chainsaw massacre.
It's probably like the 16th time I've
seen it,
but like I watched it and like man,
I had some very strong mentee and like I
was watching it and was like,
oh my God,
this is fucking unbearable.
Like I can't deal with it.
I'm going to go crazy watching this
fucking thing.
Like the woman who by the end is all bug
eyed and covered in blood and like she's
lost her mind because these Texas
fucking cannibals if like driven her and
saying I'm feeling like that.
But then I realized like,
Oh my God,
that woman running from leather face and
the whole family freaking out and
screaming,
how many people are secretly that woman
inside of themselves constantly running
in terror from parts of themselves that
they can't deal with or acknowledge or
look at.
And so,
so meditation is kind of like going into
yourself to that creepy fucking ranch
house in the middle of nowhere in your
heart and then exploring the places that
you don't want to go into him up.
You know what man?
It's as it's feeling them,
it's instead of cleaning or fixing or
repairing,
it's going in there and feeling the
whatever it is.
For a lot of people it's just grief,
pain,
sorrow,
regret,
you know,
and it's going in there and not being
like,
I'm going to fix what I fucked up seven
years ago because this is not time
travel.
But what I'm going to do is for 10
minutes,
five minutes,
I'm going to let myself feel this thing
that I've been trying not to feel by
distracting myself with an incessant
flow of thoughts and that that is,
that is when you start lightening up a
little bit because really all you gotta
do is feel as they,
I think the maps people say feeling is
healing.
Have you ever heard that?
No,
but I think it have,
but the thing was like a kid show.
That's a great kid show.
It shows him some good shit to do,
man.
We're on the ball.
Yeah.
You know there's some kid's movies that
are oddly psychedelic dude.
Are you kidding?
Like,
oh,
kids are psychedelic,
like to appeal to a child.
It's like you do have to create some
crazy shit.
You know what kids show isn't find me a
kid show that isn't the most psychedelic
thing,
including Mr.
Rogers.
Like Mr.
Rogers is like,
that's some trippy shit going down
there,
man.
Wow.
Trippy.
It's funny that you bring up Mr.
Rogers because here's what,
one of the things that I was going to
say when we're talking about gun control
and violence and all the different
issues in this world,
what one thing that we don't concentrate
on is promoting being nicer.
Yeah.
Like,
no,
no government official does that.
Presidents don't do that.
They don't get on TV.
They sort of say it,
we need to work together,
but they don't.
They don't ever say,
folks,
we just got to figure out how it'd be
nice to each other like,
do we not in conflict anymore,
but we're designed for conflict and
here's how you get rid of that golf.
Get a fucking heavy bag.
Go Run hills,
go to yoga class,
eat better.
Stop drinking so much coffee or alcohol
or sugar or whatever your,
your vices.
That's fucking with your body.
Get you.
Get your body in order and get your mind
in order and just be nicer to each
other.
That would fix almost everything.
If people just overall decided,
you know what,
Male,
female,
whatever the fuck,
whoever you're talking to,
just let's just be nicer to each other.
Yeah,
let's just,
everybody do this.
Can we all just work on this?
No one's saying work on this.
Like there's no government officials.
There's no big state of the Union
address and go,
ladies and gentlemen,
our problems that we have with each
other,
ridiculous.
We're family here.
We're brothers and sisters and we're all
immigrants.
Every single one of us as an immigrant.
I'm not saying we should let everybody
in,
but whoever's here,
you made it bitch.
He made it.
As long as you're not a God damn
criminal,
you made it.
Woo.
So growth the tax dollars and get taxes
from him.
Also,
don't forget we're all immigrants coming
from infinity to,
exactly.
We're all immigrants who've come in to
this dimension and have complete Amnesia
as to what was going on for the last 13
out of a vagina.
All of a sudden you're American.
Yeah,
that's it.
We're all immigrants and,
and,
and I hear about this.
I can,
I'm starting to run now,
but I have to tell you,
this does your,
about this Canadian couple.
There's a gay couple that a had twins
and they did it through a surrogate and
they,
they mixed up their ges so that no one
knew,
which,
you know,
who's just was who's,
well,
one guy's an American citizen and one
guy's not.
Yeah.
So the kids were born and they did a DNA
test on the kids cause they wanted to
find out whether or not one of those
kids was a dirty Canadian.
Turns out one of them is trying to sneak
over our borders at one day old fuck
off.
So they set that little fucking
terrorist back to Canada.
Gay couple married in Canada sues US
government for denying citizens to the
child.
Hey assholes.
Let these fucking people come back.
Jesus Christ understand man.
Like people like jeff sessions see a
picture like that and they feel like
they're looking at somebody taking a
dump on a crucifix.
Like for a lot of these people,
they can't handle the idea of gay people
having kids.
It's not like they're worried about
citizenship.
It's like a lot of these gnarled Fox who
are running things.
They're terrified of gay people.
You know,
that's,
it's,
I'm sure that you ever made that
decision.
It wasn't anything
to do with like,
oh,
this is citizenship laws.
It was like,
hey man,
we're not going to have this futuristic
shit where we're doing some kind of ges
co Combos here.
We're not doing TJ's combos.
And my country just used
one of those little a paintbrush.
Those things you stir with,
you know,
like if you want to make a butter
coffee,
here's a little blurb.
Oh,
is gonna Lecture Electric Away?
That's what they do.
They just into like a mixing jug.
How they use a fucking,
they use like smoothie machines,
man.
They just,
sure positive.
A buddy of mine was telling me today
about,
um,
uh,
he was in Berlin and when he went to
this,
there's this club and they had three
different floors of this club.
Like one floor was like a hardcore,
like punk scene or you know,
electronic scene or something like that.
And then below it was a hardcore gay
club.
Heard of this class,
hardcore gay club.
They would have shit night where they
would shit in the tub where and seal it
up and bring it in there.
They would just all over the stage and
they would dive on the ges like a slip
and slide and slide around on each
other's Tj's they'd piss on each other
and this is just,
well I get the ges and the pests,
do you,
but help me understand this shit.
That tupperware shit thing.
Like the problem is I opened up with the
top worst shit.
I went too hard off the gate.
I should've,
I should've dialed I shit.
I should have started with Jizz on the
deck and then they slip and slide then
work their way up to piss nine each
other and then these crazy motherfuckers
started bringing in shit.
That's what I should have done.
But when I don't understand,
it's like they're like the slip inside
slide.
It's like,
yeah,
you know it's like fucking fun night.
You're like enjoying like some physical
found with your paths,
but like why are you bringing in like
shit and Tupperware?
Like what's the like smell and shit?
They're like smelling each other's shit.
So you're just like,
hey,
take a whiff of this great shit I had
the other day.
Well,
do you know how some guys like the smell
of their woman's vagina?
They want to get in there and smell it.
You know,
I wonder how much those connected,
cause that's where you put your Dick.
I wonder if you put your Dick and butts
all the time.
He'd be like,
I want to smell your shit.
Oh,
like it's associated with light or
reminds you of fucking or something.
Mike,
this is what I want you to do.
I want you to shit a tupperware and
bring it over.
Are you serious?
Jim?
Want you to shit?
Nothing.
Bring it over and don't wipe your ass.
Tupperware.
Like why not foil?
Hmm.
Who knows,
man?
I mean you'd have to be really fucked up
to want to smell someone shit.
That pad.
Yeah.
Smell each other's shit.
Maybe it's just like a naughty thing.
Like we're being naughty.
Smell my shit.
Yeah.
Or I'm transporting shit like you're
like I'm,
I'm,
I'm bringing shit somewhere.
Like I'm bringing a lunch to this place.
It's by the way,
I've heard of this club man.
My friend was telling me about this car.
I don't know if it's the same club.
I think it is.
I've been hearing all this shit about
bad ass.
Berlin is man that it's just like crazy
over there and that this one club my
friend was telling me she went to,
everyone stands in line.
There's no VIP.
Yes.
Everyone stands in line like part of the
experience of the things you stand in
line for like a long time and there's
one bouncer,
he's giant.
He's like this giant scary German guy.
I think he's got like a glass eye or
some Jesus and he's scans you so you
stand in front of him and he looks at
you and like does some kind of soul scan
and if he decides you're ready to
experience the psychic effects of
witnessing dude's sliding through calm
because you know for some feet cause
it's not as though he's trying to like
he's obviously trying to keep it cool in
there.
Right.
But he's also trying to keep people from
losing their minds because like the one
wrong person goes into the sub basement
and sees a bunch of people huffing
tupperwares shit and doing like do you
know and the sliding through jazz,
you know that could be like a push you
over the line that could lead you
straight to fucking mail bomb land.
You could just end up in a cabin
building devices of destruct that it's
probably happened to kids.
Then
if you took any of the people from the
trump,
he bear commercial and put them in that
gay club while those guys are smelling
each other's shit and Tupperwares and
jizzing on the floor and pissing on each
other cause they just wandered into
their accidentally.
They'd all start fucking probably.
Have you seen that video?
The trumpy bear?
I put it on my instagram last night.
I was watching tv in this fucking thing
came on and it's like a tim and Eric
Sketch.
What is it?
It's like a,
it's a real commercial for real stuffed
animal.
Look at this.
The trump be bear.
No,
no.
You got to see the video though.
Can you play the video?
Oh,
just go to my instagram.
Wow,
that's cool.
I'll put the video up on my ears.
Oh,
that's it in the upper corner.
Make that larger and give me some
volume.
Listen to this.
Listen to this though.
Great American grizzly.
Introducing the original trumpy baby.
This is real fearless.
Super plus American.
Now tell me,
this doesn't seem like a tim and Eric
Sketch.
Watch.
Watch how this goes on.
Just fine.
The secrets zipper and bull out
that's actually getting one of these.
It gets crazier.
Watch on flag day and on any American
holiday.
God bless America.
God bless.
Trumpy dare.
Trumpy bear suits.
Probably little cycle for all the
world's a see at loves to cruise with
his brother.
I'm a former marine and I'm proud to
have trump.
He bear ride by my side.
Fuck yeah.
Once a marine,
always a marine.
Everyone.
Goddamn Tim and Eric Sketch Golf course.
Look at this and I ride with trump.
He married.
He makes my golf game great again.
Trump,
you bear the bear can pop up the style
of this trademark and policing the Munis
paper chair.
I love it.
Those guys will love trump.
He did a tough one.
Thank you.
Bear business is great for businesses.
Great.
I,
I'm great.
I
love you trump.
You bear.
I am.
I am proud to own the trumpy bear and I
will always be proud to be an American.
Wait,
hold on.
That guy.
Hold on.
This is fake.
Did you see that guy's name?
Is War a holic?
That's frank.
That's frank war.
Holic like an alcoholic for war.
Go back for bro Frank War.
Holic that's a gag.
This thing's a gag.
Do that.
But it's on the radio or it's on TV
rather.
It's kind of a gag.
I looked it up after last night.
It is for sale.
It a real products,
real products.
So,
but so this is,
it's a comedy sketch.
I kind of knew it had to be.
Yeah.
There's no way it could be that bad.
Oh my God.
I know what it is.
They've made a comedy sketch that's
comedy for people like anybody who's
paying attention,
but for people so dumb that they don't
realize it's a comedy sketch and they,
they think the way the people in the
video thing.
Yeah.
It's like a honeypot for dumb dumbs.
It's brilliant because on one level it's
like a really funny sketch.
On the other level,
it's just like people like God damn,
I've always wanted a trumpy bear.
So they make this bear,
they sell this bear.
They pretend that they're all patriotic
and they just made the dump.
Of course it is.
What's wrong with me?
I am the storm.
Of course it's fake.
I was pretty sad,
but this is the world we're living in
right now.
I believed it was real because it is a
real product,
but when the lady pulled out or flag,
I've got a little suspicious and then
the other guy says,
once a marine,
always a marine.
I'm like,
this is a tim and Eric Sketch.
Pretty subtle man.
Like I like it.
Definitely.
I've seen commercials that Shitty for
sure.
Trumpy bear official.
There he is.
Once Maroon.
Oh,
a marine.
Look at my boot.
It's dirty because I work.
What do you,
what do you think?
You know,
we're,
we,
we make really shitty predictions
whenever I come on your show about
what's going to happen usually,
but what do you think is going to happen
with Mueller and trump?
I have zero idea.
I'm fascinated by the whole process.
I'm fascinated by his disdain for the
intelligence intelligence community.
That to me seems to be like in one of
the craziest things a presence ever done
is like literally have beef with the FBI
to the point where the FBI foils a
terrorist attack in San Francisco and
the present doesn't even mention it on
tv,
doesn't praise them.
Does it make a big deal about how good
our government is that we've been able
to stop these terrorists?
This is one of the reasons why I wanted
to build this wall in the first place
and tighten up illegal immigration.
Yeah.
This is an opportunity to prove his
point and he doesn't talk about it cause
he's,
he's got a beef,
got beef with the FBI.
Do you remember when the FBI agent came
to your show?
Do you remember that when that happened?
Yeah,
that was one of the weirdest.
That was like really weird for me.
It was a weird,
because the dude like the way he did it
was perfect because he got like,
it made my heart leap because he's like,
he like,
like he had his hand on my arm and like
a cop style,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and then he like lifted his shirt up to
show his FBI badge.
And I'm like,
well,
I don't know exactly what it was,
but I mean,
I could probably imagine a few things
you might be arresting me for.
But then he was like,
then he was like really cool and he's
like,
listen to your podcast.
And he's like,
you know,
he's like,
he was just being really awesome.
Listen man,
you need those people and everybody
doesn't think they need those people.
You have an unrealistic view of the
world.
You need sheep,
dog.
You need them.
You need people to watch the criminals.
You need two people to be able to solve
crimes.
You need people to be able to stop
terrorist attacks like they did in San
Francisco.
You need them right and muddy dinks it.
They don't need him.
Look,
I wish we didn't need them.
I wish we had a perfect relationship
with all the other nations and everybody
just decided to work together for the
survival of the species as a whole.
And we weren't.
So concentrating on a owning resources,
taking over governments and controlling
parts of the world that have,
you know,
things that we're trying to steal or get
or buy.
But it is so as long as it is,
you're going to need the FBI,
you're going to need intelligence,
community,
you're gonna need the army.
You didn't need the navy getting these
marines going to need the air force,
but don't the FBI,
the police,
the police like that.
Br,
the polices bullies
and that's,
and there's a checks and balance system
that's been proven.
Now,
I don't agree with this because I think
this is a crazy reason to fire a guy,
especially a guy who was a war hero,
but General Patraeus,
he his whole thing,
he got busted because the FBI was
looking into something.
The FBI was looking into something and
got the head of the CIA in trouble.
So they go after each other.
Wow.
So there's kind of a competitive thing
currently heared yeah,
sometimes they don't get along.
Sometimes the CIA and the FBI,
they don't see eye to eye on certain
things.
But this one was a weird one because it
was about an affair.
It's like of all the shit that he did
bad,
like he had an affair.
I just guys out there,
right smashing worlds with these.
What is the mother of all bombs with
though?
The fucker?
He didn't lunch that one.
That was after his time,
but they launched all kinds of crazy
bombs over there,
right?
I mean they're just shooting drones.
The fossils.
That's all good.
I heard he put your penis inside of the
wrong person,
dude,
that she lecture.
It's crazy.
Oh,
we're going to investigate where your
penis is.
Pig.
You dirty dirty boy in between killen
strangers.
You're out there.
Yeah,
she's the wrong person.
We can take all the accidental drowning
deaths you got for us.
We can't take as you shoot.
Okay.
Dirty,
dirty semen inside another woman.
You will only express love for one woman
in this world that it,
you can only feel up for one person at a
time and you're definitely not going to
put that general cock and anyone else.
But Lydia Petraeus,
your why.
Oh sorry.
So fucked up a function so fucked up.
It's so sad.
It's so stupid.
It's scary.
Like what?
The guy didn't want to fuck his wife
anymore.
That's a problem
between them.
Yeah.
This has nothing to do with us.
Is He still a good general?
Nothing.
Yeah,
it's terrifying.
I mean that's really where we enter into
the land of absurdity because this is
where it got really observe.
Like you know people that think that
there's some grand scheme to protect
people and protect generals.
A dude,
there's video of him when he was walking
from city college in New York where he's
teaching and he'd have to walk down the
street where he was going and the
students were surrounding him,
screaming at him,
calling him a war criminal and he did it
constantly is teaching there.
Wow.
Follow him from and he,
and they're filming us for the cash of
the cameras are filming them and then
people around him like,
fuck you,
cute.
And he's,
he's on his own dude.
He's helpless.
If somebody just,
they just jump them.
They just jumped him.
No one's stopping them.
I thought people like that had like
internal guards or something.
Turns out,
nope.
No Shit.
Cast that guy aside.
I mean,
I don't know if they've rectified the
situation after that day,
but that day he is by himself.
Look at this.
Turn it up.
Give you some volume on.
This is crazy.
It's crazy blood all over.
Hey,
this hyperboles not necessarily holy
shit.
It's crazy to imagine that guy sexting
sucks the fuck out at some lady.
Ooh.
Like a missile son at home.
Here's a bunker buster.
When he comes,
he whispers scenario.
Ooh,
Ooh.
It curls up back man.
Let her see.
Hmm.
Yeah,
they leave,
but they left a guy alone.
That's what's interesting.
Then you would think that the,
the amount of influence that guy had,
the,
I mean that guy was one of the top
generals,
if not the top general in the country,
right?
Wasn't it?
Yeah.
I mean he was a huge war hero.
There's been two instances of shit like
that happening.
Where,
um,
the other one was the Michael Hastings
one.
Do you remember that one?
Vaguely.
This is a fascinating one.
If you really want to fire up your
conspiracy theory,
really want to turn a pitch tonight.
Michael Hastings was a journalist who,
uh,
was embedded,
I believe it was in Iraq.
It might've been an Afghanistan,
but he was a embedded in the Middle East
somewhere.
And,
uh,
something happened.
Oh,
that volcano erupted.
Remember when that volcano erupted?
And they canceled all air flight for a
long time.
He was trapped over there with that and
they got way too comfortable with him.
And so they started talking around this
journalist,
the way they always talk and they,
and he was joking around about Obama and
make it fun of Obama and they said a
bunch of shit they probably shouldn't
have said,
but that just what fucking soldiers say
when they're over there risking their
lights or something,
they probably don't even understand.
You would want them to believe this is
all for a good cost.
Right?
You would want them to believe
everything that they're general tells
them if they got a fucking crack,
some jokes,
the president's expense to alleviate a
little stress while we're out there
killing strangers.
Yeah,
no UN,
an intolerable,
intolerable,
mocking the leader of the free world
while you're out there killing
strangers,
you can't do that.
So he made this guy resigned.
So here's where it gets crazy.
Michael Hastings starts telling
everybody,
look,
my life is in danger.
He's like,
people are threatening my life on a
daily basis.
If anything happens to me.
I did not commit suicide cut to him
driving down,
I think it was sunset car going
uncontrollably fast slamming into a
tree.
The car exploding the engine flying from
the car.
Yeah,
he's dead as fuck.
They find amphetamines in his system.
But that's adderall because that's what
all journalists are on there.
All on adderall.
Right.
So they tried it all the,
I was on methamphetamines when he drove
into a tree case salts.
Classic job,
Dick Tracy.
Yeah,
let's just forget about it.
We connected the dots.
It was quite easy.
Meanwhile,
there's people that have said with
absolute certainty that with today's
cars,
it is incredibly possible.
Absolutely credibly possible to control
the car from a remote place and make the
car do what you want it,
dude,
definitely.
Definitely,
definitely,
definitely.
But we,
I mean this is,
I love this line of this direction we're
going in here man,
because you,
it's great because it's like this to me
where it gets really,
remember that thing that people would
always say that government is always,
what is it five years ahead,
seven years ahead.
I have it tattooed on my ass.
Did you get it at a nightclub in Berlin?
You got to know the government's ahead
bro.
Huh?
But it's true.
It's true.
All that money that they have.
So where where it gets really
interesting is when you start thinking
about what that means in relation to
like computer intelligence and ai and
you start realizing like,
man,
whatever the shit is that they have
access to at this point compared to what
we think they have access to is so
powerful and so dangerous that anybody
who they want to take out,
anybody they want to take out,
they can take out.
That's a problem.
It's okay.
Having anybody to have that much power,
especially over the rest of us.
It's bad for them.
You know,
and Kennedy talked about this when he
was in office,
he talks about secret societies and and
keeping secrets from people.
And it's just generally,
it's a bad idea across the board for
humans.
It's just bad for our human nature and
to,
for groups to have ultimate power of
surveillance.
It would just look into your life.
It's odd.
I mean,
Edward Snowden proved it.
It's,
it's obviously,
it's too easy.
It's too easy for people that work there
to check on the ex girlfriends who the
fucking up.
I just have one to read your email.
Do you think there is secret societies
out there that we're not really aware
of?
Well,
if they're secret societies that we're
aware of,
that's because someone along the line
open their fucking trap.
Sure.
And they let us know about a secret
society.
That's how we found out about skull and
bones.
Right.
One of those posts he's told their mom,
yeah,
you know,
you made me sweat.
Could dig.
And they filmed.
Yeah.
No,
I'm in the order.
Isn't it like a glass coffin like glass
Dick Saca glass,
second glass Dick.
I thought,
no way.
Not your way in a glass cottage is on
you and they just on the glass,
like you're laying down and you're
looking up their glass coffin and it's
raining jets.
What if you do that to a guy and it
becomes uncontrolled?
Be Hard and just shoots in his pants?
Well,
I think you're naked in the glass
coffin.
Oh,
okay.
I don't know if they like put you in
funeral garb or whatever,
but my guess is like,
I mean it was me.
I'd be like,
you know,
I'm going to,
I prefer to be naked.
You're going to fucking splattered all
over this fucking thing.
I want you to be weirded out.
Let's go for it,
man.
I'm going to lay down face first.
You just stare at my area.
I'll try to come on the coffin from
inside.
Come on it from the APP while singing
Abba songs.
But,
but do you ever like,
I love thinking about this stuff because
I do think that there is probably,
and this is kind of what we talking
about a little bit before where the maps
don't work anymore.
I think a lot of people like to live in
a place where there's maps and they
imagine that's all there is,
but I'm pretty sure that there are
sectors of society that you just never
see and you never will see because they
have around them.
This impermeable wall of wealth,
like you're not going to get in there
like places that have membership fees
that are like $600,000
a year.
Like yeah,
I know a guy lives in one of those uh,
gated communities.
It has a golf course and the golf course
costs a quarter million dollars a year.
That because that creates this wall
where most people Gannett get into.
And then also that's crazy.
People are living in compounds.
People are living in massive compounds
that have entire teams of servants.
Like,
dude,
there's people who have eight nannies
for their baby.
Did you know that?
There's people who have,
it's because they're poor and they can't
afford 15 like a normal family.
Teenagers.
You got all the different languages
covered,
the different styles you could have
gained any straight.
Danny sees the kid likes.
But that's when you think about that,
that there they're these enclaves of
wealth that are compounds surrounded by
not just like financial walls,
but literal walls with armed guards
standing around the walls.
And inside these compounds are
communities of,
of a servant class there communities of
servants that are having to serve these
wealth,
hyper wealthy people.
That's a king and a queen.
It's a futile compound that's being
separated from the rest of the world.
And we're at least to duke and the
Duchess of Duke and the Duchess.
But I mean the pr,
it's basically the no different.
It's,
it's the same fucking thing because a
lot of the people working in there are
illegals,
so they don't even have recourse to
normal laws and stuff like that.
And so what ends up happening in these
compounds is there's people who are
untraceable who live in there.
And that is when you end up in a fucking
space suit,
sitting in a Goddamn Tesla going and
fucking Mars,
it easily,
you could put a disgrace nanny and that
fucking thing.
You know when they're really gangster,
when they have white nannies,
right?
Pretty white nanny.
The wife has to sit around like there's
someone who's always at CEC.
Always a check.
Yeah.
Husband,
not quite checkmate.
Always a check.
Keep moving it around.
Check.
Oh,
she conveniently dropped her keys in
front of Luther.
Yeah.
Look at her.
Pick them up the dirty bitch.
God fucking crazy.
I up in there.
I want you to picks up the keys.
Monogamy is so dumb.
I believe I left these keys here.
What Luther fucking nanny?
What just left the nanny likes another
cause.
Then they might kill the wife.
The wife knows too much.
Let the wife join so she knows about the
offshore accounts.
What you have to offer.
She knows about the taxes.
Dude.
She knows more than that.
She knows more than that because,
because what ends up happening in these
compounds is you do start knowing things
and you start knowing real thing.
Yeah.
You start getting the real downloads
about like what's actually happening
because these little fucking compounds,
they're all,
all those people are connected to each
other and each other.
Christmas cards and they go to each
other's parties and stuff and like they
talk and they have and they know stuff.
Man.
The way luther looked at the nanny on
bro,
come on Bro.
She dropped her keys.
You really think she dropped her keys?
Did you see that?
I did see it.
I heard,
I heard.
Yeah,
I was there.
She dropped the keys on purpose and she
stuck her house right up in the air.
He's getting a divorce.
We gotta be careful here folks.
You've got to keep this family together.
Well these people sign like,
he's like huge nondisclosure agreements.
So like there,
there's like they're wrapped up in a
veil of secrecy anyway,
but that's not what you have to worry
about.
Where you have to worry about.
It's Harvey Keitel from pulp fiction.
That's you have to worry about to worry
about someone making a phone call and
some guy who works at some fucking ray
Donovan in real life guy who works for
rich people who can make a lot of money.
Imagine if you're friends with a
billionaire and this billionaire is a,
he's in a situation.
Yeah,
no,
this is fucking guys.
Just,
you know,
he's got pictures of my wife and yeah.
You know,
he's trying,
he's trying to,
he's trying to get some money out of me,
man.
I don't know what to do.
Well,
so we can make this disappear for a tidy
sum of $200,000
Dun,
and then all of a sudden that guy just
isn't around anymore.
Yeah.
The guy just gets picked
off and you ever like would investigate
it gets paid off and then it's like
nothing happens that's just disappears.
Just take him into the middle of the
ocean.
Well,
it didn't,
wasn't there just this billionaire
Canadian couple that got executed.
Executed in their house.
Yeah.
It's like shit like that and there's
some sketchy deal.
What would their connected to?
It was the Clinton Foundation.
Was it Jesus fucking Christ Jesus
fucking Christ.
Oh,
Joe with you and your conspiracy
theorists about the claim.
Yes.
It's all coincidence after coincidence,
after coincidence and,
oh,
did you bring up seth rich again?
Let it go.
No.
Suspects shot in the back in front of
his house.
Four in the morning.
No robbery while it remains,
phone remains watch remains private
investigator and he's the guy who gave
up all the DNC leaked emails.
He gave them up to wikileaks.
Nope.
Just coincidence.
Yeah.
Muslim,
nothing.
He gave up the linked emails that show
that the Clinton campaign absolutely
worked their fucking black magic to get
Bernie sanders knocked out.
Oh God.
Stop.
Stop Dude.
How about haunting man,
but at that video again,
put up that picture ends and he's
showing me murdered Canadian billionaire
couple barry and honey sherman.
Several people murdered them.
It says several.
Wow.
Crazy.
That's crazy.
They got whacked.
Hey,
they fucked up.
It fucked up.
What did they do?
Didn't have a big enough army around
them.
They didn't have the army.
Look at Duke and Duchess and you're
going to hang out with assassins.
Tried to save money on security.
You know,
if I was running a security team,
I'd show them.
I'd be like,
take a look at these guys.
They tried to save money on their
security team.
Yeah,
right.
Okay.
It says real to discover their bodies
dangling from a railing near their
basement swimming pool.
I like that it says suspicious like,
oh yeah,
this seems a little suspicious.
These billionaires are just hanging
here.
It looks like they were a strangled and
they died from a form of strangulation
called ligature neck compression.
That means someone wrapped a rope around
their neck and choke them.
Gorat that is,
that is a personal way to kill someone.
That's very personal.
Yeah.
That's intense shit man.
And these are old people,
70 75 years old.
If you google that,
it is not pretty pictures that you get
back.
I don't want people's faces that can
print it out that Oh yeah man,
you don't want that.
Don't want that to happen to you.
See this is the,
this is why I think it would be scary
like to be friends with a billionaire.
It's like it would be scary to be
friends with someone way up at the upper
ups because like you almost don't want
that level of access.
Like it's almost like,
look man,
you guys fucking do whatever you're
doing up in your compounds.
Drink from the iron skull.
Come on the fucking coffins.
Open the portals,
pull out the squids.
I'm enjoying my life down here.
I really don't want to know.
Like I,
I would prefer to like to just speculate
because here's the thing man.
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
Please go ahead.
It,
there's levels to everything,
right?
There's,
there's levels to the weirdness that's
involved in immigrant communities that
all keep the same language.
They all stay together.
They huddle up together,
their signs and their same language and
then it becomes like a Korea town or a
chinatown.
The,
I'll just huddle in that area and stay
in that area.
There's weirdness to that.
This weirdness to billionaires doing,
getting together.
We're all just going to do a billionaire
shit together.
Yeah.
We're all going to hang out together.
Any special clubs and those leather
chairs,
those with the buttons on them,
you know,
it's leather chairs.
They're like smushy.
They have like puffy and then the
buttons and then little buttons all over
him.
It's a high back leather chair.
Sit there and perhaps there's a little a
nightstand right next to you with the
cigar.
Ash tray tap that will serve our ass and
showed down and they bring over Cognac
and you sift cognac like a gentleman and
you talk about where you're hiding your
money.
You talk about a w,
you know how you got rid of the syphilis
before the wife found out?
You talk about,
uh,
how you're,
you're helping to trump get into
position to make sure that you could
drill in Africa wherever the fuck you
going to do it.
This,
this is what they do.
They get together.
How the fuck?
Who else is gonna know what they're
talking about,
right?
And it's,
and it's fucking generational.
And some of them start going crazy.
Like that cop,
that cop boy,
oh boy.
Do you know the cop boys making those
dumb shirts?
If you seen that fucking,
have you seen this shit?
No.
Oh Dude,
you gotta see this?
This is like,
boy,
this is the,
is k o.
C.
H.
This is the progeny.
This is like the demonic antichrist.
Progeny of like,
oh,
the Koch brothers.
The Koch.
Oh yeah.
Cause it's coke not cock the god of Toy.
Yeah,
they're fucking cowboy.
Dude,
this is like,
this is the,
and this is what the antichrist looks
like.
Everybody thinks the antichrist is going
to be smart and in like in like
nefarious and focus like Demian.
No Dude,
he's gonna like make fashion shirts.
Like look at this shit.
Let me see what we got here.
Billionaire Air Wyatt coke makes shirts
about money.
I drank blood this morning.
Wait a minute.
It's the shirts are about money.
Can you,
can I see those pictures again?
That looks like pink handcuffs with
keys.
How's that about money?
Because that's what I paid for.
Paid be handcuffed.
Are you,
are you allowed to show these videos of
him?
Like dancing around and his shirts and
shit.
It's actually been removed.
It's unavailable.
Somebody got it
dude.
It's the weirdest fucking shit
everywhere.
He brings his whimsical ideas to life
with his retina blasting shirt.
Bray Wyatt Ingram.
So why at Ingram is his shirt brand?
Yeah,
but you got to look up an interview with
him cause he says shit like daddy told
me I could do whatever I want and I am.
Look at this chick ooze that his girl
picked up bigger.
God Damn,
I prove I'm on his side.
If a guy who looks like that can get a
girl looks like that,
you go,
boy,
what am I a man hater?
Huh?
Am I one of these asshole men?
Shoot other men down.
I'm not their guy.
He didn't even bother even think once
about losing weight.
I'm not either.
I'm just using weight.
Look at my Zeros.
I'm just using that as an example of the
progeny of billionaires.
Like these people are like,
this is like something that this shit's
spilling out of the mansions man.
Like look at this says here,
blessed this oafish coke air and his
hideous shirts.
He's a flamboyant guy and now we're
talking about them.
Good for you sir.
I'm sorry coach.
He's smart.
He's,
he looks like the guy who sold the
dinosaurs in Jurassic Park.
Remember the dude,
what's his name?
The guy from Newman Newman.
He looks like Newman and he's banging a
10 I mean you get the fuck out of here.
Also,
it looks like he's been spending a lot
of time in the skull and bones come
coffin.
Aye.
I,
I'm not satisfied.
I haven't absorbed all the energy of who
come into my being.
Who knows,
man.
It's just,
it's just weird over there and on the,
I look at him,
I hope he has a giant Dick.
I think that's the Dick and the left
pant to the left pant where the yellow
is like,
it's kind of bulges out where the yell.
Yeah,
that's his cock.
Giant fat.
Like a quaker oats box.
Scary.
That's him coming and it's like,
it's like one of these water bottles.
That's what it's like.
It's fat like that terrifying and the
end of it,
it quivers terrible seats like the demo
gorgons mouth on stranger things.
The end of it,
it doesn't have a slot.
It has like a little flower thing.
That's the very end.
Every time we do an episode together,
we end up describing some form of alien
caulk every single time.
Like I know,
I know the last one we added a
description of it.
Yeah.
That's scary.
Very immature.
How dare you?
I think it's important to like speculate
on the different types of potential.
Alien Cox.
I think Cox go away.
I think cox or this is a temporary
situation.
100% really?
Yup.
Yeah.
I think that's what aliens are.
That's when you see the aliens.
They have no Cox,
no Cox,
no miles.
We're going to get rid of this mouth
communication.
Going to get rid of this a cock and
pussy.
Fucking,
it's horrible.
No,
no,
no.
We're going to mind meld.
It's going to be like dmt every time.
You're not even going to want to have
regular sex.
If you could,
if I could give you the gift of being
able to travel through space wherever
you wanted to go,
but you had a nub down there.
You're Cox gone.
No,
I'd be like Doctor Manhattan just
sitting on Mars by myself.
I'll board.
Fuck that.
I like it here.
He'd rather hump.
I like America.
I like being right here.
Yes,
Angeles.
Goddammit.
I like it.
But you wouldn't want to see like float
at the edge of the tiny little dick
crying as I slide through infinity like
this.
Look it down and up.
I have like a Dick,
like memorable.
They shrank Dr Ken's Dick and the the
hangover.
They've made it like so small.
You couldn't even it.
Remember that
would be what it was like.
I know,
man.
If he's so sad.
Yeah,
and you'd live forever with no debt.
No flying through space.
Just a nub buck board.
Listen man,
I'm not into deals.
I like what's going on right now.
I don't want to hear you.
Heaven deal.
I don't want to hear your space deal.
Yeah.
Good.
I'm good right here.
Well,
I mean,
don't you ever,
I mean this are,
and this is another thing we taught.
We've done these so many times.
We're going to repeat of course,
but like dude,
one of the,
I do worry about you sometimes for him
because it's like,
I think you're going to get,
I think it's finally going to happen.
I think one of your fucking guests is
going to come in here with a briefcase
and he's going to show you something and
I don't know,
like an alien piece of where the
spacecraft was going to be.
Tom Delonge.
I was hoping he had something.
No,
I think you're going to,
you're,
you're accidentally going to get access
for some reason.
I think somebody is going to give you
something or show you something and
you're in like I,
I worry about you man.
Cause it's like,
yeah cause you've got like you now have
a platform that is unlike any platform
that's happened.
You know,
because you're doing like a comedy
podcast,
radio show style thing,
but you're also interviewing people
about really heavy duty Shit and sure.
You like pepper it up with freaks like
me from time to time.
Just for it up.
Yeah.
But like you have,
you make it sound like the,
the other people or the on the main
agenda and mum patches pepper and up a
little Duncan trussell.
Well No,
I'm just saying like what the fuck do I
know?
Like you're having people on you talking
about you and I have had my all time
favorite podcasts.
Thanks.
I haven't my all time favorite group of
people.
If I had like a handful of 10 people to
pick forever,
just do podcasts them forever.
Yeah.
You are 100% on that.
I appreciate that.
It's you and D as an Ra.
There's a few other people callen but
there's just a list of people that are
just forever.
Yeah Man,
I love doing podcasts.
You don't you ever say that?
If it's between you and some fucking
scientists want to prove to me that,
uh,
telekinesis is real.
Go with you.
Please take the scientist,
then we'll do it your
podcast after.
But Dude,
I'm telling you,
don't like knowing all this shit.
And there's so many times when we've
done this podcast where you and I have
started talking and the elite,
the hair stands up on my arm and I'm
like,
dude,
like we,
we shouldn't be talking about some of
this shit.
Like a,
like a,
like it gives me the real Heebie jeebies
and then sometimes I'll admit this to
you,
sometimes when I'm super stoned,
I'm thinking about all the podcasts
we've done.
Sometimes I think to myself,
fuck ap Joe does know something like
maybe you did end up getting some kind
of little like shoulder,
uh,
with them where they're like,
not literally your shoulder up,
you just brushed shoulders.
And they were like,
Hey,
we love your show.
We love your show,
man.
They didn't even say anything.
They just showed themselves to you a
little bit to be like,
hey look,
don't fuck around man.
Don't fuck around.
Like you could talk.
We don't want,
we are funny.
We liked the way you talk,
but don't fuck around
man.
Don't you ever think that?
Hmm.
No,
because I'm not like you got dammit.
Plus I don't keep those Cami ideas
floating around inside my head.
I got a Goddamn American flag behind me.
Gun Control.
The fuck you're talking about.
I'm friends with a ton of cops.
You got an American flag with a fucking
cow's skull above it.
It's actually an Asian buffalo from
Australia.
There was arrowed by my great friend
Adam Green Tree.
Wow.
One of the best bow hunters on the face
of the planet earth.
Wow.
He shot that thing.
Yeah,
but I mean it's like brought it to me
remembering my friend,
remember when we did that show,
I remember we did that at this but it
was kind of we is it.
As the show progressed we became
increasingly sort of despondent and find
realizing cause we're both retired.
Tell him that we here,
maybe we were going to find an alien.
Like both of us secretly thought.
It became very frustrating because you
saw the same thing and everybody you saw
this delusional belief in a logical
things that they would argue.
They would argue illogically the,
there weren't objective about the actual
evidence versus what they wanted to
perceive the evidence to point to there.
We're all biased in which I've been
biased before.
Everyone has been biased but it was just
delusional.
Everything.
Everyone was delusional.
Everyone from the first Ufo guy to the
first chem trail got to the first big
foot guy.
They were all either liars or delusional
or they had errors in their thinking.
And then occasionally we would talk to a
guy like that one dude that we met that
was in the trailer that told us about
the balls that would fly through the
air.
Yes.
Well after that I heard a podcast with a
physicist who a guy was a lightening
expert who was talking about ball
lightning.
They don't know what causes it,
right?
They don't know why it exists even.
And this guy was that it was on radio
lab and it was fairly recently,
and this guy was actually saying that
lightning itself,
uh,
doesn't make any sense.
Like it's not supposed to exist.
If you're measuring all of the energy in
the skype is something that we don't
know about what the formation of
lightening is,
that it shouldn't even exist.
Shouldn't be possible.
Right.
But this ball lightning is not only
possible.
It's been observed many,
many times and it's even happened inside
of an airplane.
What floated down the aisle inside of an
airplane and multiple people witnessed.
People have seen ball lightning,
they've gotten video of bald lightning.
And what it looks like.
Is that exactly what that guy was
describing to us that this thing came
through his house and then just
disappeared?
Yeah.
Remember he's talking about totally
remember and he did not seem like a liar
to me now.
I think he saw ball lightning and I
think that area knew that skin Walker
ranch place in particular is for
whatever,
whatever causes that phenomenon.
It happens more frequently in that area.
It's very possible because there are a
lot of people over there that saw some
shit share,
man.
I mean,
but,
but this,
that was disappointing,
but that was the most revealing.
It was revealing in the guy.
That was a weird area.
Yeah,
it was weird.
There was a fucking weird area.
But don't you like
imagine that?
Do you ever do this game?
There's a fun game or you start thinking
about who the smartest person on the
planet must be.
Like the continuum of intelligence game
where you start thinking like,
okay,
I know I land somewhere on the continuum
of intelligence.
I know there's people that are probably
not quite as smart as I am and I know
there's people who are way fucking
smarter than I am.
And then you start thinking of yourself,
who are the,
who are those people and what and what
are they up to?
And then you start thinking,
see,
this is what I think about.
If I were you.
Then you start thinking like,
fuck man,
I've got this podcast that lots of
people listen to.
Is it ever happened where maybe some
really intelligent person has
manipulated me and an attempt to get me
to disseminate some kind of information
out into the world.
Good luck manipulating me.
Duncan Trussell,
I'm an American.
Flags don't run or something.
What happens is colors at least know
what's up,
bro.
But you wouldn't even know.
That's the thing you wouldn't even know.
I wouldn't know.
How would I not know?
These people are people we're not going
to be like if they're,
if someone is super so good at
manipulating people that can manipulate
me and it changed the way or think about
them.
Yeah,
well then good luck.
Right?
I mean,
but that's like the thing is like this
is,
again,
I'm not trying to make you paranoid or
anything,
right?
It's just,
but it's fun to think cause it's like
this like,
okay,
like let's imagine for the sake of just
fun,
we established there these fucking
billionaires and they live in these
compounds and they,
and we've also established that
certainly people like mice thing,
Michael Hastings and other people,
they get killed all the time.
Might have,
but I think you got killed because he
got a fucking major general fired.
Well they what?
What did we establish their general
during,
they're super powerful people who will
use technology to kill people to have
their own way.
So that means that there is some group
or a series of groups of people that are
you doing or like highly nefarious
actions from a place of power.
I'm just paranoid.
Or you're not connecting the dots here.
Maybe he was on speed and drove into a
tree.
Then the honestly I do not know.
But the,
his very fun.
Yeah.
To think that it's a conspiracy and they
killed him.
Very Fun.
But if you look at Ockham's razor,
you know if you applied ockham's razor,
the most likely scenario is that he just
drove into a tree that's not very sexy.
Here is a way to kind of help out with
Ockham's razor with these kinds of
things.
It's just think,
okay,
I have $100,000
and I'm going to put bets and this
awesome casino where the truth is
revealed.
So are you going to put the money down
on him being assassinated?
Are you going to put the money down on
him being on speed and driving into a
tree after he said,
if I commit suicide,
it's not a suicide.
I got to meet the guy.
He might that might've been thrown
people off.
Get to meet him.
Maybe he wanted to leave a fucking
story.
Maybe this guy's like,
you know what?
I'm just going to have these people
think.
Did I got fans,
man?
Shit,
ah no,
no dude,
I
know where you'd put your money.
I know where I put my money.
If it was like 50 bucks.
Yeah I'm going to bet on conspiracy
cause this is deciding if I lose 50
bucks,
I won't feel that.
I feel like wow fuck hoes is hoping to
win.
But you're like,
I'm just saying man,
how do you deal with being on the
fucking radar man?
Because like the thing is like if there,
if there is an interest in controlling
the pair and the reality tunnel,
like we know that there is a Wa like
truly a award to control the paradigm
because if I can control the paradigm
just as a cool thing,
this is,
I agree with you,
but I don't think it's a united front.
This war to control the paradigm is most
tightly fought between left and right.
It's most tightly fought in,
in government.
Right?
In the real things.
Well we're doing is commentating on the
sidelines.
Yeah.
You know,
if I'm an influencing anybody,
I'm influencing people by pointing them
to information that I see that's already
out there.
There's a big difference between these
people are in power against each other,
right?
There's gotta be some people that are
influencers that get access or get shit
upon,
especially in the age of trump,
like if you're an antitrust and me,
if he finds out you're against him.
He's got like,
he's very vindictive.
Like he calls don lemon a moron,
and he shits all over those CNN host and
call CNN fake news.
But Sean Hannity and Fox and friends,
he'll praise them in his tweets.
Like there's an information war going on
with these people,
but they're paying attention to right
and left assholes like me that are like,
what am I?
What am I?
I'm a fence sitter,
you know?
I mean it fucking,
Ron Paul was running for president.
I'd probably be like,
I'm in,
let's see how this works.
Right?
I like what he's saying.
I like his ideas.
He,
he was,
he was a guy that when he was running
for president,
I was like,
okay,
well this is,
this guy's clearly a very honorable
person.
He's clearly a very honest person.
I mean,
by all accounts.
Let's see what he does,
what he does.
what happens.
Let's see what that,
it's gotta be better than just knowing
you're being bullshitted.
So many of them are just so obviously
bullshitting you that you're listening
to.
These can fucking speeches and you're
like,
God damn it.
I don't resonate with you at all.
Right?
This is that presidential type of
address where I talk in a way that
you've never heard a normal person
talking in your presence before.
You might say to yourself,
well,
that's weird man,
but I got to talk like that when there's
a lot of people now you don't.
You don't.
That's not real.
And I don't understand.
You put a shield up and the shield is a
an act.
You have a presidential act.
Sure.
Or you have a strip club Dj act,
right?
Well,
you have a morning Dj App ride five
o'clock past the hour.
Here we go.
Led Zepplin houses of the holy,
the ocean,
Dat,
Dat Dah.
Yeah,
I mean that's the fucking voice.
I've heard that voice a thousand times.
It's a goddamn costume that people were,
you also have a fuck voice.
Don't forget that.
I don't have a fuck boy.
So you don't,
oh,
come on,
let me put it in.
Talk like you wouldn't fucking crazy.
Do you?
You,
um,
you don't have a fuck voice.
Come on.
Sorry.
They won't hear my voice.
Yeah.
It's time to fire.
You Do,
do,
do.
There's so much shame and wanting to
fuck.
Ooh.
She wants to fuck itchy vagina or vagina
needs it to get scratched.
Yeah,
man.
It's one of the,
definitely one of the tragic parts of
society is that people feel shame about
that.
I love the scene in game of thrones when
Cece,
what's her name?
[inaudible] the beautiful darcy.
Thank you.
When service,
he's walking naked down the street.
They're going shame the shame bell shame
and the shame bell APP on my phone.
I used to,
you can get the shame about lap.
Whew.
Yeah.
I don't have any more.
Why is it too much?
Having too much power.
We're addicted to the shame factor.
People delete their facebook off their
phone.
I know people that like regularly delete
their facebook.
They fucked us.
They just take it off their phone.
I can't do this anymore,
man.
Too much power with the shame bowel man,
but people,
there's a lot of dudes.
You ring that fucking shame ballot girls
all the fucking time,
man.
It's the worst.
Yeah,
you're ruining the whole vibe.
Yeah.
Well you know what it is.
Cause guys feel terrible when a girl
leaves them and fuck somebody else.
If they want to make it like very
difficult to write new man.
Right?
Sex more than one man.
You've dirty little bitch.
Yeah.
Or if you're like not of your
polyamorous,
then like the yoga,
they call you a cock because you don't
care that other people are fucking hippy
talk for when you move to Cuba or
wherever the fuck.
I don't think they listen
in America.
You get a fucking wife and that's it.
Greedy Bitch is an even number of people
over here.
This ain't China son want to go live in
China has this like fucking 10 guys,
10 guys
guys,
everyone check.
You're going to wind up but fucking
other dudes.
Oh well fuck it.
Yeah.
You say come coffins all day,
baby.
That's what happens in prison.
People get crazy.
They start having sex with men.
You just gotta.
You gotta figure out a way out of prison
or having sex with men.
Figure out a wig.
Gotta get rid of your,
come comes,
got to figure out a way out.
What's the best way your hands are going
to have to fuck guys or something?
Shit,
this is bullshit.
That's,
that's what happens if you live in
China.
That's what happens.
If I don't have real,
real lesson here to learn,
but if there's more than 10 to one men
to women,
well don't they have,
they have some crazy problem over there.
I'm not making this up.
They have a prick.
Joking folks.
Obviously I'm joking,
but there's a crazy problem over there
with,
uh,
the ratio of men,
women or is the ratio.
Let's take a guess.
What is the ratio of men to women in
China?
I meant like 60,
40.
It might be bad news.
It might be higher.
That's danger.
Might've made that up.
That's a dangerous,
it's a spooky ratio.
I've read the ratio.
It's not a good ratio.
Spooky fucked up ratio.
Well,
you know,
for the long time they had limitations
on how many children you can have,
which is just fucking take gen x.
They messed up the whole thing.
It's not just that man,
people were killing their baby if they
found their baby was a girl.
I mean,
this is a real thing.
It didn't happen everywhere.
It didn't happen all the time,
but there absolutely were girls that
were drowned because they were girls
because the family wanted a boy and if
you don't think that that's the case,
you're delusional.
I think you're delusional.
I think if you put those kind of
restrictions on intensely poor people,
in some of them,
in some parts of the country,
they're in terrible poverty and you tell
them they can only have one kid.
They don't want to have a boy because
the boy is going to help them work.
Right.
I don't know if these stories of them
drowning baby girls were true because I
wasn't there.
Those stories persist.
Sherry ever snope them,
but I don't think they know either.
If you weren't there,
what happened?
Brutal.
Fuck.
It's a horrible thing to think to have a
baby and then just drowning.
He's,
it doesn't have a deck,
but two people have done that.
People have left babies and garbage
cans.
I mean people have done a lot of
terrible things to babies.
When I was a kid,
I,
um,
worked at a place called Newport
creamery and it was right next to a bank
and a girl that worked in the bank was
pregnant.
She never told anybody she was pregnant.
She gave birth in the toilet and left
the baby in the garbage.
They found the baby in the fucking
garbage dead.
And she got arrested.
And this was a girl I used to go to.
I used to go,
she was a bank teller.
I would go to the teller.
She like,
she was,
she seemed awkward,
you know,
she was at Carnegie dates or anything.
No,
I did not.
She wasn't checking and she was a large
woman,
which is why nobody could tell that she
was pregnant.
She was big and um,
she apparently had been pregnant and
didn't tell anybody.
And nine months pregnant at work and
just had the baby in the,
in the toilet and threw it in the
trashcan.
And I don't know if she didn't take the
trash out.
I don't know how she got busted.
You imagine going into the bathroom and
you're taking a shit and you're like,
why does it smell like baby in here?
Because that smell and then you look
into the wastepaper basket.
You see an I gotcha.
That is so fucked up.
So fucked up.
That was a real person that I knew.
The country with.
The highest gender disparity of birth
isn't China.
What is it?
Lichtenstein.
Oh,
where's that terrible,
sad play.
Okay,
let's find out what the ratio of men to
women.
It's the same about 33 million more men
than women.
So it was like 733 million men and 688
or something like that.
Okay,
so it's like nineties.
That's like in the nineties isn't it?
Says Christ.
Man,
that's crazy.
It's still a large number.
Thank God for sex robots.
They're going to better though.
It's better than I thought it was.
Um,
within 115 males.
Every one.
Go ahead brother.
115 males to every 100 females.
China isn't the country that most store.
That's crazy.
Imagine if you're in a room,
there's 115 dudes in a hundred girls.
It's like a crazy chair thing.
Like,
Shit,
I've got to find a cow.
That's one's worse.
Where and linkedin sign,
it's 126 males to every hundred,
but there's only,
there's less than 40,000
people in the whole country.
So it's even worse.
So the cause the cause there's less,
less possibility.
Fuck man.
Magic.
There's a country that that's a crazy
country.
37,000
people.
That's a crazy country.
That's that.
Countries like Burbank.
No,
it's not even burbank.
Yeah.
No.
It's like,
what's 37th that,
let's take a guess.
A part of La has 37,000
people in this Christ.
37,000.
That ain't,
that's nothing out here.
Like boulder is 100,000
in boulder seems so quaint.
That town is one third the size of
boulder.
I mean that country has one third the
size of boulder.
That's amazing.
Wow.
When you think of it that way.
That's amazing.
As many people as in culver city,
I imagine if culver city,
he was a country.
Whoa.
Beverly Hills is 34,000
that's amazing.
So it's beverly hills.
It's beverly hills as a country with all
dudes.
That's amazing.
With all dudes,
just like Beverly Hills,
that gay couple things satisfy.
Fuck.
Imagine people have a real hard time
with the idea of gay people raising
kids.
They get real angry.
I just can't think that all gay people
are the same.
Why would you not think that some gay
people would be good at all kinds of
things?
There's going to be gay people that are
great carpenters.
There's going to be gay,
like gay people.
Just like straight people is going to be
awesome ones and it's getting me ones
that are fucked up.
The idea that they wouldn't be good
parents.
Wouldn't you rather have two gay parents
that loved you than a a mother that's a
fucking crack head and a dad that's
piece of shit beats you to gay people
that let you be yourself.
You know,
just they're,
they're cool and conscientious.
They just happened to be homosexual.
They love each other.
They hug in front of you.
You realize like,
we're all wrapped up in this bullshit
of,
you know,
men and women,
Chilean be together,
heterosexual people like ourselves.
We get weird when you think of someone
who's homosexual,
like I'm fully in support of it,
but when,
if they started fucking right in front
of you,
but like,
hey,
I got go.
Whereas like if Dunkin started banging
his girlfriend right in front of me,
I'd be like,
do you want me to cheer you on?
How you want me to handle it?
Just watch.
Okay.
Don't look at me when you come though.
That last time was weird.
I was just like,
look over.
Oh,
ah,
make eye contract.
They,
but it's like,
I,
uh,
I've seen guys kiss in public and a part
of me is happy for them.
Pardon me?
He's like,
that's awesome that they're so
comfortable in 2018 now 17 at the time,
maybe even 16.
I seen him a couple of times.
What had one time I was driving and uh,
I was going from the comedy store.
I took.
Right.
And then I went down.
Is it
doe Heeney which treat is it?
One of the streets that goes right to
Santa Monica Boulevard,
which is like full rage,
gay central.
It did just dude's in the streets party
and there's this big gay club with guys
on Poles and shit and this is two dudes
and they were hanging out and they uh,
there were belt Lupin.
We're like,
they each had their hands on the other's
belt loops,
like,
like anchoring in and they were just
grinding on each other and kissing.
And I was just,
I was in my car.
I was like,
oh Jesus,
Jesus,
deep moving.
Don't stop here.
I was like terrified.
I was like,
the car was stopped and they were right
there.
Like belt looping and making out,
okay.
Simulator.
You have access to any experience you
want and you're in it for,
I don't know,
a hundred thousand years.
You're like some in a mortal being how
long before you simulate fucking a dude
joe?
Well,
you know what happened?
Marlon Brando.
Yeah,
he fucked prior eve also fucked Marvin
Gaye.
What a roster.
Wow.
He's just really into talented black
eyes.
Yeah.
Wow.
But you're not answering the question.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
In the simulator,
how long,
how long before you started having sex
with you or you decide to have sex with
a guy like in a simulator,
it's like the,
for like 10 thousands of years you're
having,
you know any kind of you can,
you,
you can literally fuck anybody that you
want in this simulation and you're,
you're in there for a long time.
So you go through fucking every single
possible iteration of woman ever.
You just fucking fuck it three ways,
six ways,
thousands of ways.
You're,
you're like,
you're just laying in a rain forest of,
of beautiful pussies squirting on you
and fucking,
and everything that your mind could
think of sexually.
You're just doing it.
How long before you start adding coq
into the equation?
Well,
I think if we did an experiment where we
both took a journey like that,
where I'll see you will be just like we
are now,
but it would be a hundred thousand years
of whatever you want later.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll show up hundred thousand years.
Now.
You will have dick on your breath and I
won't,
I would've gone to the whole hundred
thousand years with no gay sex cause I
could do whatever I want.
Why would I fuck dudes?
I would have sex with girls and then
when I was done having sex with girls,
I would take a nap or I do some other
shit.
Meanwhile you'd be like,
I got to stick it somewhere.
Maybe true man.
Yeah,
I would,
uh,
I would get to the finish line and I'd
be like,
no dude,
finish line.
I'd be like,
yeah,
made a hundred thousand years,
hundred thousand years.
That's the race.
No Dick for a hundred thousand years
made it right.
Cause Your eternal he is.
He does have girlfriends,
man.
Why would you start sucking Dick?
Well,
it's about that time who look at your
watch,
but after a couple of years,
like posted a couple of months,
come on man.
Why is a hundred thousand years
any different than 20 years did 20 years
ago?
You feel less likely to suck a Dick and
you feel today?
No.
You,
you're the exact same God damn human
being other than you've learned and
gotten better at life,
your desire.
You still like the same shit.
First of all,
I want it,
I just want to go back over it.
Cause you said at the end of the hundred
thousand years,
I,
I've,
I've to him,
I had a breath.
Here's the thing in my simulator and my
simulator Cox are going to like have
different flavors.
It's not going to just be cock.
It'll be like an owl toy.
That's how they get you.
They get you by Minox.
I hate to say this to you,
but you dicks,
um,
you dictates terrible and you need to
get it.
You'd get it.
Mentee,
there's way is a way and then guys are
going to suck it and then they're going
to get meant in their mouth.
Just like if I,
if you suck my Dick,
you get mint in your mouth.
You want to fill it,
just let it just try it.
I don't,
I know it seems weird,
but it'll get your mentee.
I will fully admit that the end of the
hundred thousand years,
I have sucked dicks in the sex emulator,
but the fact that you think you haven't,
I would like to do a poll,
like I'm going to get to the end.
I'd be wearing a cowboy hat,
bare chested,
that's riding a horse of fighting off
with every fiber of my being,
but I make it,
I don't want my bare chest and I'm bare
chested with a Bandana.
Like I'm close,
I'm close.
I'm shaving my chest with a straight
razor and the front mirror at the
barbershop.
I'm super close to go and gay,
but I don't.
I make it to a hundred thousand years
clean.
I have cowboy boots on with no socks.
You lose the race wrong.
I fucking,
when I don't have dick on my breath at
the end of the race and I don't have
those dirty memories either.
You have dirty,
dirty Mary's idea of butts and shit and
Tupperware and slip and slide with just
stopping with,
I'm suck enough dinosaurs.
That's right.
You could have anything you want.
You can.
You can but fuck a unicorn in the sky.
Yeah.
Why not?
If you could do whatever you want,
if you can do whatever you want,
you would like full chart.
Like if your life was a virtual
experience that you can control with
your mind is if you have a control
panel,
you would just start talking decks and
Ami.
I'd be bulletproof robbing the banks.
I'd be fighting vampires.
I didn't make a whole world.
I would do a bunch of shit.
I'd fly,
fly all over the place.
It wouldn't land.
It's suck a dick.
Yeah.
You know,
if you ever heard the Alan Watts thing
about this,
you ever heard Alan Watts to talk about
this?
I'm going to talk about a lot,
but not about that.
Did he really know?
He talks about,
he does this great thought experiment,
which is like,
okay,
if you were able to do anything you
wanted,
right?
You've definitely heard this,
but you,
if you were able to do anything you
wanted,
if you are an infinite being omnipotent
and you can do whatever you want,
you would experiment with making
everything and you would try everything
and you would do everything.
We're talking about infinity.
You're,
you're literally in the state of
creative flow for infinity and you're
going to do,
he has a great lecture that I'm going to
butcher.
You should look it up cause he's so,
he's such an articulate genius.
Like the
essence of the thing is eventually,
eventually upon crew doing everything
and creating a universe and creating
planets and creating a planet where
there's life on it and being a God that
communicates with the beings on the
planet,
you're going to start thinking to
yourself,
I wonder what would happen if I made
myself one of the beings on the planet
and couldn't remember that I was God.
And that's what you are.
That's what we are,
is we are one of the experiments of the
divine seeing shit.
I wonder what happens if I forget that
I'm capable of creating anything that I
want,
whenever I want,
that I've made the entire universe.
Let me turn myself into this hyper
limited version of myself with no memory
of what I was in.
Play that game at that level.
Cause it's a lot more fun.
It's amusing.
It's exciting.
Right.
And that's,
and,
and that's when Alan Watts starts
talking about which cox he would
simulate inside that machine.
No,
no.
But yeah,
it is.
You ever heard of Marshall Mcluhan
speak?
No.
His,
there's some interesting youtube videos,
um,
on,
with the,
you could watch Mcluhan talk and he
doesn't look at anything like you'd
expect.
It's really interesting.
But his,
uh,
Kalki not in a non one say,
calculated his scientific dissection of
like what's happening with media and
what's happening with technology and
where the future lies is so fascinating
because it's from the 1960s.
Yeah.
And you know,
he's talking about the media is the
message I think is the name of the
lecture and the book.
And that was the same book where he
wrote one of my all time favorite quotes
that human beings are the sex organs of
the machine world.
Like this guy had no internet.
He had,
I mean nothing was like anything too in
the bet.
And most electronics they had,
it's a goddamn calculator and it had
nothing to computers.
They have were giant rooms filled with
shit.
You know,
like,
yeah.
But somehow or another he saw where it
was on Cohen.
He was seeing things and and pointing
things out just with the very nature of
our ability to communicate in our
ability to innovate and where it was all
headed.
Yeah.
Fucking fascinating cause you think
about how it did play out and no one saw
this common man.
All right.
But no one saw common was what we're on
right now.
Right.
Internet,
this fucking new thing where people can
just find out the answer to like we've
done so far today about scientific
questions about descartes car.
Yeah.
Can periods that these,
this was constructed and when did this
happen?
And 1,079
what?
You know you,
you're,
you're getting a download like anybody
that's ever lived.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Everybody can do it.
That this is the thing that's making the
boundaries between us and the leaders of
the world.
This is why there's such a problem is
because we have all the information too,
right?
Everybody has all the information.
Yeah.
And the only thing that's keeping it all
glued together as tradition,
the only thing that's keeping the
hierarchies into the position of power,
they're out right now without being
completely abandoned and restructured
from the bottom up.
The only thing that's keeping them
together as tradition,
that's it.
What do you mean?
The only thing that's keeping government
and just borders and nations and the
whole concept that were existing,
that there are a bunch of different
countries and there's a bunch of
different leaders and this guy controls
the,
sure,
sure.
The only thing that's keeping that
together as tradition.
The only thing if,
if we eventually can communicate with
each other in a way that for goes all of
the current limitations and all the past
limitations,
something that bypasses all that stuff
it takes,
one of the first things is going to go
is the illogical traditions.
But,
but it seems like its traditions being
guarded by dudes with guns.
They are,
but those dudes with guns are going to
die and new young dudes with guns,
you're going to take their place.
This is just a,
I mean it might take generations,
but this is what happens with ideas.
It just happening so fast now and some
of the people with the old Id,
they were born and raised with the old
items.
They're still around.
They're still stuck in this old
sistance.
Right.
But then this new system has blossomed
around.
They're trapped shitting
bricks.
They're shitting bricks and they're
trying to stop it.
Exactly.
And they're actively trying to stop it.
Did you hear that shit?
Jeff sessions said,
I don't mean to keep harping on that
guy,
but he,
he,
he said that like he just came out again
saying that he thinks that the opioid
epidemic as they call it,
is being partially fueled by marijuana
is a gateway drug that uh,
marijuana is getting people on a
painkillers,
which is a completely raw,
it's not,
I mean,
not only is it,
is it wrong,
it's like they can show statistics that
seem to indicate that the opposite.
The opposite.
Yeah.
But that crazy fuck is saying it
publicly.
Like it's real and it's not.
And the too,
just the fact that like,
that man is allowed to continue having
his job,
which theoretically somebody who was in
his position should be so hyper aware of
the data on all drugs because a person
in that position,
we need a person just like you were
saying,
we need shepherds like this fucking
fentanyl shit,
man.
I,
one of my friends,
he lost his,
his,
his wife to this.
So I ended up so many people are dying
because of this.
Like we know a couple people that have
died from it.
It's terrible.
It's Tom Petty.
It's so sad.
It's terrible.
But we need,
so we need to have some regulatory
force.
It's making sure that these poisons,
but they're not regulating that they're
going after the stuff that's the most
safest,
the most beneficial.
Medicinal.
Could you imagine having a podcast with
Jeff sessions?
Is You sitting across from Jeff sessions
for three hours and talking to him about
things?
Dude,
I've heard and this is like,
I hate this.
I smells like salt.
I hate
to say this.
I don't want to say this.
I've heard he's like funny and he's
like,
likes to argue and he's cool out with.
That's what sucks.
Yeah,
you want them to be like smelly.
Say that.
But if you had him on a podcast,
I bet you chip away through all that.
All those,
that party personality,
no,
these people,
this is a problem,
man.
These people,
they're not lizards.
They're not lizards.
That's a problem.
If there were fucking lizards,
if only jeff sessions was a fucking
lizard.
The problem is it's like they're not
like that.
They're just,
they're confused.
Yes.
Mass does sessions.
Podcast is one.
Thank you.
Father.
Know,
the problem is we have to have
compassion for these people because
they're not bad.
They're misguided and they're informed
and they can be turned around with the
proper experiences.
Right.
And if they're willing to abandon their
previous notions,
but the problem is so many people are so
invested in their identity that it's
impossible for them to give up.
Their notion is just like the
Egyptologists.
I don't want to look at the possibility
that may be there've been doing these
fantastic constructions in Egypt a lot
longer than we think,
which is entirely possible.
It doesn't mean that the great pay,
I mean take it back to Egypt one last
time.
Like no one's doubting that the Great
Pyramid of Giza was constructed at
somewhere around 2,500
BC according to the previous or all the
data that we have right now because
they've been able to carbon date stuff
that they find like in between the
stones.
They're pretty sure that it's somewhere
in that range.
You know,
they're off here.
They're a little bit,
but there's some other construction that
John Anthony West pointed out that's
buried under sand.
They find that's like wait,
like it might've been buried for who
knows how fucking long.
And it's a different style of
construction and it looks really old.
Like one of the things about the styles
of construction and the things that they
find in,
in,
um,
in Egypt is a lot of it is buried in
sand after why even the Sphinx itself,
you know,
when they found the Sphinx.
And one of the things that one of the
people that is in,
uh,
some of the ancient hieroglyphs,
it's attributed to being alive at the
same time as a scroll.
I forget which pharaoh,
but he heard in a dream that if he
uncovered the Sphinx,
that he would become pharaoh of Egypt
because it was covered in sand,
like to,
he had written down at that time and
this was like 2000 bc or something crazy
like that.
It was covered in sand then.
Wow.
They don't even know.
I mean there's so little they know about
you made it and why you know the answer
to this.
How,
and this is probably a dumb question,
I'm sorry,
but not deep as the sand out there.
Like how far down does that fact?
It's a very good question.
That's a very good question.
When does the sand,
here's the other thing is in San from
oceans beating down rocks.
Yeah.
I mean that's what sand is.
This,
that's what's the most fucked up thing
about the desert.
There's,
there's no goddamn ocean,
but you've got so much sand.
Yeah.
That is mostly from,
what isn't it?
I think sans mostly created,
it's probably created few different
ways,
but I think it's mostly created by
oceans beating down rocks.
Right.
So that's just time.
You're just looking at time.
The craziest fucking stamp of time.
We can look at it.
Yeah.
How long does it take for an ocean to
turn rocks into a Goddamn desert?
Holy Shit,
dude.
What is under this is Sam Mega Lake.
Oh,
I need the sands of the Sahara desert.
Scientists have discovered evidence of a
prehistoric mega lake.
There's a monster down there using
images of wind blown sediments,
sediments produced by running water and
bedrock seen by radar beneath the desert
sands.
The geologists piece together,
the profile of an ancient wow.
So goes the sand goes 69 to 141 feet in
the Sahara and three feet in the Simpson
desert.
I don't know where that is.
The depths of sand varies widely around
the world.
And I know 141 feet.
Wow.
141 feet of just sand.
So am I right?
That sand is created by the ocean
beating down rocks.
I think that's true most of the time of
maybe it's not true all the time.
It's so nice to be so stupid that you
just ask.
Sounds Fun to figure it out.
Like you get to know,
like it's great.
No idea.
Yeah.
I was,
um,
talking to a Neil degrasse Tyson the
other day and he was trying to explain
to me,
um,
uh,
escape velocity like any,
he takes my shoe,
he goes,
let me see your shoe and he takes my
shoe and he goes,
now if I throw this up in there,
it's going to come down.
But if I throw it hard enough,
it will escape the pull of the gravity
of the earth.
And once it's free,
it'll go on forever.
Yeah.
You see it?
They're like,
wow,
that's fucking cool.
Yeah.
Like he tried to like put that in your
head like,
wait a minute.
What
goes on forever?
Isn't that the problem?
Now this it sky,
this is great to just dummies talking.
Yeah.
Isn't this the problem with the moon is
that not the problem with the moon,
but if you jump on the moon,
you can escape the escape.
Like it's easier to get out of the
escape velocity.
The moon.
No,
it's one six.
Earth's gravity.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I thought we started on the moon.
You can like,
no,
no.
Can theoretically you can jump higher.
And if you believe in NASA,
bro,
there's some videos of guys jumping
around on the moon.
Yeah.
The problem with the videos of people on
the moon is that there are videos that
look 100% fake,
but guys fall forward and it looks like
they get yanked up by wires.
There's a lot of video that looks fake
as fuck.
I don't know if it's fake.
I don't know if it just looked fake
because it's one sixth of the Earth's
gravity and we don't know what that
really looks like until you see it play
out.
But there's some videos of guys falling
down face first and getting yanked back
up.
It looks like the yanked by court.
Have you seen that picture of that thing
that looks at Jamie?
What after we talked about this last
time,
some people send in videos of an NFL.
Players do the exact same thing in the
end.
Yeah,
super
athletes.
It's three or four guys doing throw
their body,
but they don't have a giant pack on
their back.
And when wearing helmets,
they're wearing helmets.
That Shit's light compared to what the
astronauts are wearing.
Dude,
astronauts have like a once in a suit
that keeps them grabbing a drink concept
is the suit.
If there,
the concept is they're not even on the
fucking moon and then that suit,
it could just be paper Miss Shea,
but some of the ones where they're
pitched completely forward and they just
go badly what it is.
I'm trying to find it right now.
Yeah,
I would love to see it.
That's interesting.
So you,
you're still wavering on whether we went
to the mint.
I'm more weight.
I'm numb.
I'm too dumb and uneducated to really
know.
Right.
But I am wavering more on the
possibility that some of the footage was
faked super quick.
It's a five second videos like no.
Interesting.
Go ahead.
Boom.
That is not the same thing Jamie.
I can do that.
Super similar bull shit.
That guy goes to,
I'll do that right now.
Find another one.
The guy goes to his knees and then uses
his momentum.
The pop up from his knees.
I've seen some that look pretty crazy
though,
man.
Dude,
that's ridiculous.
The moon ones are way more preposterous.
Better examples in that though.
There's super athletes.
Yeah.
What they're doing is springing up and
you can see the kinetic energy from
their legs.
It's forcing them up.
They're super athletes,
right?
They,
they show off.
Those guys do back flips and shit all
the time there.
They are physically capable of doing
things in a normal person cannot do,
but they're not physically capable of
defying physics.
What you're seeing in a lot of those
moon videos looks like someone's defined
because it's like they pitch forward and
they bounce back up.
I think they shot a bunch of shit and I
think some of the video,
if you're going into space and you're
experiencing deep radiation,
the van Allen radiation belts and from
the sun did,
you can't even go through the fucking x
ray machine at the airport,
the old x ray machines with film.
They wouldn't let you.
Cause if you went through with Phil and
would kill your fucking film,
so how are they getting these perfect
videos and photos and none of them are
fucked up by radiation.
It's entirely possible that they did go
to the moon,
but they faked a bunch of the film
footage because they wanted to have
something and they couldn't really bring
anything back.
It's entirely possible.
There's fake footage from the Russians.
100% is a precedent.
The footage of Yuri Gagarin when he's
circling the earth for the first time
and he goes on a rocket and the first
guy in space,
it's fake as fuck dude.
He's inside this tiny little compartment
and all sudden there's,
they've got ruined there for a camera.
Get the fuck Outta here bitch.
You See a light source this way,
the light source.
That way he's got dueling shadows behind
him cause they got lights set up in
there cause they're filming him inside
this capsule.
No,
he shot up in the space.
You really did do it but they couldn't
fit it.
Bad damn camera in his tiny little
capsule.
Right.
It's,
there's no room so they just faked it
after the fact.
Make sense?
Of course it makes sense.
A lot of money.
There was no internet back then.
There was no vhs tapes back then.
They broadcast something on tv as far as
their eyes and their mind goes,
that was the only time people are going
to see it.
Right?
All they have to do is show it to you
once,
pull it off.
Nobody ever imagined you'd be able to
pull it up on your phone or to stoners
like you and me.
We'll be watching on a podcast.
It's even find the video of Yuri Gagarin
from inside his,
what would you call those things?
Pods.
Pods,
which call it Yuri Gagarin in space.
You Watch it.
You go get the fuck Outta here.
You watch it and you go,
what?
That is fake.
That is not him or this.
Not Him in space rather.
So your nose and blast off.
Here he is.
He's getting on the bus studies.
Headache to space.
I can't believe it.
You're ready?
Show me where are you?
Right,
so he's in this state.
Look at that.
I didn't back it up.
That was it.
That's it.
Watch this.
Are we good?
We're good.
We're going to strap up.
How am I go and turn off to look at the
lights?
You see,
hold up,
back up,
back up.
Stop.
Pause it.
Leave the shadows.
Shadow to the left.
Shout out to the right.
This is fucking lights in front of them.
They would lights in there.
He's in his tiny little cat.
This tiny little pod.
How's it lit up?
No,
maybe they just have,
I don't want,
I mean it's still windows.
Why couldn't they have lights in there
joe?
Because they've got no room had it seems
like there's enough lights back then.
Think about these candles.
They campfire you fire in there.
I saw a few breakdowns of the moon
landing two that said it would be way,
way,
way harder to fake it back then than it
would have been to actually just,
I read that too.
Yeah,
I've heard that too,
but I don't think we're talking about
faking going to the moon.
You're not understanding what I'm
saying.
We're talking about faking footage,
not talking about faking going to the
moon like I think they probably did go
to the moon,
but I would imagine that at least some
of the footage you're seeing is horse
shit.
From what I,
I wasn't obviously alive then.
It was like a 140 minute live stream.
No,
no,
it's not.
No.
If you,
if you just have people in orbit,
it wouldn't be hard to fake.
Look,
I think it'd be harder to go there.
That would be to fake it.
I think going there,
if they did go to there and I think they
probably did was an unbelievably
difficult thing to do,
but like thinking that they were there,
how hard would that be?
Like?
Like after the fact like filming
footage.
We're filming footage of them in orbit
and is the part you can't,
that would have been a mile of film Joe.
It's really interesting.
Why do you know that all that Shit's
missing?
You know all the original footage is
missing.
That's the weirdest fucking thing,
man.
Yeah,
I know you're doing,
you're being skeptical guy.
I looked it up.
It's missing or a bigger one that only
that you know what else is missing but
telemetry data,
all the ones and Zeros that show the
location of the capsule or whatever the
fuck it is on the waist.
I thought from what I read,
they still have that data that just the
original like paper,
it was on it.
The original magnetic tapes got reused
because they needed to.
Okay.
Well why would you say that?
Unless you just,
why don't you just google it and find
out?
That's what I read.
I read when last time,
you know,
what'd you read?
I read that that original tapes got
written over because they needed to
magnetic tape because there was a
shortage at some point.
Right.
So but still,
but the date is still somewhere else.
There was a short,
they recorded over the original tapes of
the fucking moon landing.
How much of a shortage of magnetic tape
do you have?
Where are you going to record over all
of the video from the mother fucking
moon landing hank it.
We got a presidential parade from 76 you
want to keep that?
Yeah,
Kate,
that keep,
that's a good one.
It's like if you're going through like
your family's vhs tapes,
like what do you want picnic from 82
yeah,
that was when Mikey threw up.
Save it,
save it.
They're saving everything,
but they record over the fucking moon
landing.
Let's just fucking record over the first
time in human history.
Literally the craziest thing in human
history to ever record.
Oh,
it is the dumbest thing in human.
I'm not saying they didn't do it.
They might have,
the official story might be legit
casino,
but it might not.
Where do you put your money on the moon
lighting?
Because you know what?
I'm detecting Joe when we first got to
be friends,
as I recall,
you didn't really believe in the
moonlight.
I didn't believe in it at all and then
you went through a phase because if the
podcast and having a lot of
conversations with different people or
something happened where you started
shifting your ideas and thinking,
we did go to the moon.
No,
I started shifting my ideas about
everything.
Or Moon landing is just an example.
That's an extreme example of a position
I took that I think represents there is
there is mystery to that story.
Yeah.
There's a lot of mystery to that store
is still to this day.
There's a bunch of weird shit connected
to the moon landing a lot of it.
So when I,
and people are like,
no,
there's not shut up.
No,
there is,
there is.
There's a bunch of weird shit connected
to it.
How about the fact that they give a
fucking moon rock to a,
was it the Prime Minister of Holland,
uh,
Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin and
Michael Collins signed on this plaque
and they gave this moon rock to this guy
in Holland and it turned out to be
petrified wood.
It was fake.
Like it's,
there's so much weird shit connected to
the moon landing that it makes you go
like wow.
Right.
Creepy speeches that Neil Armstrong gave
25 years after the moon landing,
talking about uncovering hidden truths,
patrice protective layers that are,
you know,
oh great deeds that could be done to
those who could remove one of truth
protective layers.
This is a speech that he gave.
There's so much weird shit.
Some people say there's alien relics as
people.
Ridiculous.
There's no evidence to that.
But there is evidence that these people
are talking really weird about the moon
landing.
Jamie,
can you peel a clean set?
What Clinton said in his book,
he wrote a book called my life and in
one of the chapters in my life he talks
about a conversation that he had been a
carpenter when people landed on the
moon.
He was working in a construction site
and the guy said,
I don't believe it for a second.
Those television fellers they can fake
anything.
He says.
Back then I thought the guy was a crank,
but after eight years in the White
House,
I was starting to think that maybe he
was ahead of his time.
Now this is what bill fucking Clinton
wrote in his book,
my life.
Wow.
Why would the fuck would you ever write
that if you were the God damn president
of the United States for eight years and
you're saying,
hey,
maybe the guy who thought we didn't go
to the moon was right,
might not be right.
It might be that they faked some
footage.
They did fake some photos.
There's a photo of micro Colin's who's
on a moonwalk from like Gemini 15 and
it's not a real photo.
It's a photo of him from the test runs
that they did.
It's in a warehouse and it blacked out
all the background.
It's been proven.
They reverse the image and blacked out
the background.
You could see the two of them,
if you overlay them line up perfectly,
it's the exact same image,
right?
So someone,
whether it is a,
uh,
you know,
an overzealous pr agent for NASA or a
journalist at the time who actually made
that photograph,
but somebody did and tried to pass that
photo office space.
So there's some deception.
We know that one is 100% sure.
So then you look at the other ones,
you look at the videos of guys falling
down,
getting yanked back up and the bouncing
around like they're on trampolines and
some videos where they're hiding behind
the lunar rover.
Like,
what the fuck are you doing?
If you guys tear your suits,
you're dead.
Sure you guys are jumping around on the
moon.
Like you're having a party up there.
Is that real?
Right?
How come I can't get a fucking regular
camera through the radar machine?
The extra mission at the airport?
But you guys can fly through the
radiation of space and that should comes
out,
but what will,
those cameras were insulated.
There were different kinds of camera.
The camera is not true.
Housel bad said it.
They were the same God damn cameras.
It's a regular camera.
There was no specific protection.
There's nothing unusual about the
protection that those cameras had.
It's interesting,
man.
You've like gone back.
No,
I haven't.
I think it,
this is the thing,
man.
I'm not taking any position.
You're agnostic 100% because I don't
know anything about space.
I don't know anything about the physics
of space travel I go to,
I don't know anything about the
requirements of technological
requirements,
but I do know it's one of the only
things that happened between 1969 in
1972 and it's not cheaper,
easier and faster to reproduce today.
It's weird.
It's a weird spent a year.
It's a weird thing.
This is the only time in history.
People have been more than 400 miles
from the earth's surface was always moon
missions,
all the Apollo missions,
man,
everything since then,
all the space shuttle stuff inside 400
miles satellites,
you know,
like a space station.
You talk to people about that part and
they'll say like,
we just don't need to go there anymore.
Maybe we don't.
Maybe they're right.
They might be right.
We don't know.
But it's juicy to think they're not
right.
But it's interesting how rapidly people
fight off the notion.
Here's the other weird shit about the
Nazis were running our space program.
That's a fact.
Operation Paperclip,
Varun Navon promise a fucking Nazi.
They brought all the scientists over
like legit Nazis who would hang Jews in
front of their fucking rocket factories
in Berlin.
Git guys who were,
we're tattoos from the Holocaust,
identified Wernher von Braun talked
about him being in there.
That was the head of NASA.
That was the guy who was trying to get
us to the moon.
Yeah,
dude,
there's a lot of
weird shit and now you're getting deep
bend to it.
It's the Nazis doing some kind of thing
where they're like trying to fake the
moon landing like at some out get to
attach to the Nazis.
I think the Nazis were the best rocket
scientists available.
Right.
Or one of them other than the ones that
we had here and then the ones the
Russians had,
there was a lot of competition to get
the best rocket scientists but some of
the best rocket scientists were in Nazi
terms.
Sure.
So when Nazi Germany fell,
operation paperclip took place and in
Operation Operation Paperclip,
they brought a number of Nazi scientists
from Germany secretly to America.
And one of them they put as a head of
fucking NASA.
Yeah,
this is where the,
this is where it gets really cool.
Someone was explaining all this to me
about how basically it's the thing is
like,
okay,
you think in World War II that we just
rounded up all the Nazis and they just
disappeared.
And it's like,
what do you think are the Nazis went and
they bought the ones who were really
good at making cool shit yet we'll bear
aspirin.
You know,
like the,
the idea is that the nar aspirin.
Yeah.
Well look up.
I'm so sorry to ask Jamie,
but do you mind looking up bear as
brandon psych on be like and,
and,
and the Jewish slaves?
I think working for bare aspirin,
but when you look at like a lot of the
core,
the idea is that the Nazis didn't really
go anywhere.
They just started corporations and some
of the biggest corporations we have
right now.
Or
do you know why Zyklon B is I clumby
because icon beat took the smell out of
it is I climb a,
was the stuff that had a sea,
an agent in it that made it smelled
terrible so you could smell.
So when they used it to gas,
the people in the concentration camps,
they changed it so that it was a
undetectable.
Yeah.
Did,
did you,
what would it say?
What does it say?
Jamie is quick with the trigger here
today,
getting frustrated with us changes the
camera.
So if you guys aren't the Bayer Aspirin
company is finally apologize for the
inhumane acts of its parent from
including using Jewish slave laborers
during the Holocaust.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
And there's all kinds of examples of
this and where it gets really weird is
like this is,
this is one of the great conspiracy
theories is I think the Bush family is
somehow wrapped up in it.
That's where it gets weird.
It's like the,
it ends up getting wrapped into American
politics.
It's like,
Oh,
do you think that the Nazis just became
rocket scientists?
Do you think they just know they became
pharmacists,
pharmacists and they started running the
companies and corporations and then like
they,
and they're still here and their
descendants have lots of money and like
to think that they went anywhere is
nuts.
The Nazis didn't really go anywhere.
They just went deep into hiding.
They just sink back into the immune
system of society.
Like you know like the way aids hides in
different parts of your body.
They just hid in the shadows.
And this is one of the reasons people
are freaking out about the kind of like
um,
friendly emergence of some people who
are like clearly white nationalists who
are just kind of like being like
interestingly accepted and embraced for,
you know,
what's at least have a rational about
how you want to start a white ethno
state.
You know,
that kind of stuff because it,
who's doing that?
Well,
I mean,
isn't this something Richard Spencer
talks about it,
but who's taking that guy and talking to
them rationally?
Well,
there's these,
a lot of these people are getting like a
lot of airtime,
but I think this is a bit of an
exaggeration.
You're like,
maybe we're talking about Steve Bannon.
Steve Bannon got into the White House
and a lot of people state their name is,
but he has,
he,
has it been proven,
I mean it's really easy to call a guy
and a white nationalists.
Has it been proven?
I don't know much about Steve Bannon.
I don't know what,
honestly,
I think a lot of,
I think,
I think some of these people,
it's,
I think it's like God,
I mean,
you're going,
I'm going to get like a fucking,
I'm going to get like an avalanche of
like you're a fucking guy,
tuck,
Tuck Kami.
But I think like for example,
when you look at trump's reaction when
they were saying asking about the KKK
and he's like,
I'm not going to talk shit about this
group.
I don't really know him.
Remember that like,
or the fact that a lot of like,
I think you're paraphrasing.
Um,
he,
I think what he said was,
uh,
a little more acceptable but still
weird.
Can we look at it?
It's like a little tip telling.
It's like if someone's like,
Hey Kay,
Kay Kay,
what do you think?
Well,
he's also said something about there was
people bad behavior on all sides,
on all sides.
And that's one of the,
one of the white nationalist groups
picked up on that and said specifically
that trump didn't criticize them
specifically.
So this was a good thing.
The whole thing was very good for them.
It's like a white nationalist groups
said that,
but that could have been just him just
not doing a good job preparing.
What are you going to say about
something and talking off the cuff,
which I think he does with most things.
I think that guy does most of his shit
off the cuff.
Yeah,
he,
you know,
he said that and one of the things that
he said,
but in the wrote that book,
the art of the deal,
he doesn't make plans.
He just goes,
it just goes to work and gets things
done and just work.
Work off of instincts.
I don't know.
The thing is like,
it's generally like when you think of
certain people,
right?
Are they a white nationalist?
Like when I think of you Joe,
are you a white nationalist?
No.
Right.
It's simple.
It's like there's no like,
well you know what?
Even a nationalist,
I love America,
but I'm not a nationalist.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So the problem is with some white what
you don't want.
This is one thing I don't want,
I don't want there to be a blurry thing.
When people think of me about whether or
not I'm a white nationalist,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't want there to be a like,
well maybe he does have some kind of
ideas that are based around the
importance of upholding European culture
and making sure that we do everything we
can to prevent people from having sex
with people from other races.
I don't want there to be any question,
but like I have zero problem with
everyone humping everybody whenever they
want mixing the Paints and doing
whatever.
There is no question.
I don't care.
Like I think it's fine.
Whereas some sounds like what a racist
would say.
What do you mean?
Trying to like divert attention away
from your racism.
I said,
what the fuck you're doing?
I see what you're doing,
man.
This is virtue signaling but virtue.
Oh,
do me a favor.
I hate to dwell on this one more time,
but you please go.
I want to make sure I'm right about
this,
that the hassle bad cameras from the
moon landing weren't insulated in any
bizarre way.
See that up there are set.
They were different cameras.
They were mates a specialty while they
were made for this chest thing.
They also had a special special film
developed developed by Kodak Special
Film.
Is that true?
Because I read that it was exact same
film.
Who but who says it?
Who says it has a big breakdown?
I'd look it up.
It had a pixel,
which is a big cause too many fucking,
there's too many different people
commenting on it that like,
like me,
like I'm muddying the waters myself by
not exactly knowing what the fuck I'm
talking about.
Well Dude,
I mean that's,
I look at the camera or behind the
historic w what is this?
Who wrote this?
Had a pixel.
This is a pretty well,
this is fucking shell to shell site.
This is CIA front.
Even the shadows,
the lighting,
the lighting.
Why is it so well lit?
It's in the shadows.
God dammit.
There's a guy behind it with one of
those big reflector booms.
This is on in Nevada.
There's a tarp back there.
And uh,
if you look real close,
you could,
uh,
see gum wrappers,
films,
listen,
look at all that gum wrapper and fake
round.
We've got fake that ground looks,
oh no man,
look at that.
Look at it.
Shitty tin foil on that spaceship.
Yeah,
super likely.
That just landed on the moon.
It's just more fun.
This is why I abandoned the idea that we
didn't go to the moon.
It's more fun to think that we didn't go
to the moon.
It's more exciting.
So I have to be careful going that way.
That's why I changed my opinion on it
because then I started really looking at
him like,
what the fuck do you know about space
travel?
Almost zero.
But what do you know about bullshit?
I know I'm the law.
I'm good at bullshit.
I know about bullshit.
And when I watched that press
conference,
the Post Apollo 11 press conference of
Mike's Samoans,
but bullshit shit,
something's weird here.
And I think it's entirely possible that
they were forced into,
uh,
accepting some stuff that wasn't real
in,
they kind of knew it,
but that they probably did go to the
moon.
I probably don't understand how you're,
this is like get back and forth in your
head.
When I say alien artifacts on the moon
right away,
you're like,
no,
I don't think they leave shit behind.
I think if they're smart,
they uh,
they clean up.
Have you not seen the clean up fucking
rack?
There's a division of alien.
No evidence they'll look the face on
Mars.
We've looked at women really well.
Picture of that space ship that crashed
on the moon.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
That shit looks crazy.
Of a real,
I like to think that you space ships.
I think they get to a certain point,
they just traveled through dimensions.
I really do.
But think of that more and more.
I don't think spaceships exist other
than like the really crude civilizations
like are relatively,
oh,
that's super real.
Which one do you mean it's most drawn
with crayons?
What the fuck is that?
It's roaming.
That's an episode of Star Trek,
Bro.
That looks like a ship,
like the eyes of a mountain line behind
it.
Come on,
man.
The eyes look at this is a fucking
volcano.
Look,
look,
that's a fucking topographical map.
That's you're isolating a tiny little
area and you're choosing to look at it.
You got to ship.
How dare you.
You could look at anything in Moab,
Utah and decided that that's a space
ship.
This is why they don't want to go to the
middle ground.
It's the fucking ground.
There's a hole in the ground that's a
ship.
It's not a ship.
And look at that trail.
It's like a bobsled trail.
You know what's interesting?
We look for Shit on the moon or in space
in general,
and a normal thing in space is fucking
amazing.
Like if we find a microbe on the desert
floor,
no one gives a shit.
Oh look,
your lives in the sand,
it's incredible.
Nobody's going to pay attention.
But if you find something in space and
you can prove that this thing exists,
it was a living organism,
a primitive organism that's on Mars.
So we know that some life existed on
Mars.
Right.
And then take it another step further.
If you ran into some dude who was
jerking off in your apartment building,
you just open the open the wrong door
and some dudes in there jerking off and
he's screaming and he's an old man.
He's got a tank top on.
What the fuck can you tell your friends?
We'd laugh at it,
but if you found that guy on the moon to
some old Dude Jurgen off on the moon,
imagine if that's what we found.
I went to anyway,
go crazy.
Realize you realize like like that.
We literally are in a simulation and
this is how we find out.
There's a guy on the moon jacking off
and he's got boxer shorts on and socks
with crocs and he's just sitting there.
He's probably knuckles up,
right?
He's sitting there with a hunchback
knuckling up on the moon and he got
dirt,
but he's got mouthfuls a dirt.
That's how he gets by.
That's the creator of the universe.
He's just gone crazy.
The creator of the universe went insane.
Now he just jerks off on the moon.
Oh,
it's an old man.
He looks just like an old man.
She was like,
the universe is so infinite.
There's an infinite number of
possibilities that lives can exist.
Like someone's explaining this the other
day,
that the infinite is so vast that
literally it's entirely possible.
There is a darth vader somewhere like a
real legit darth vader who runs an
empire.
Like it's real thing somewhere.
That's how many possibilities exist.
So if that's the case,
why can't there be a possibility on the
moon of an old dude who eats dirt?
He's got a tank top and spaghetti stains
on it.
He's knuckling up on the moon.
Nah,
Nah.
We find them.
We have to film them front page of the
New York Times.
They found an old manager and off of the
moon.
Do you think they tell us if they found
an old man jerking off in the moon?
It's like that's what they find.
Like the space probe lands and then
right in front of it's like fucking look
at this guy's great ball hair.
He's,
I'd love see this left press conference,
half his guts hanging out,
spaghetti stains all.
How do you give it spaghetti stains on
his shirt and no one knows.
No one knows he's eaten dirt on the moon
jerking off on the probes.
Now what?
Now?
What are you going to do now?
What is our civilization to,
how do we deal with this?
Well,
it's the same thing.
It's like this a elon musk car in space.
It's like you see the image of that car
flying through sprint.
You're like,
wait a minute,
wait,
is this real?
Is this really going on or am I in it?
Goddamn movie,
right?
Like what's happening here?
It's just got to really spend $100
million a shoot a car and it space.
What the fuck is this?
Sure,
he's got a camera on it.
It's broadcasting images of a mannequin.
Find what the fuck is going
on,
man.
Cascading levels of absurdity.
That's what's happening.
We're seeing cascading levels of
absurdity and like the more that it,
the more that absurdity happens,
the more normal it seems.
Yeah.
And that's kind of I,
this is what I've been thinking is like
what,
what the apocalypse really looks like
because everybody thinks when you think
about the apocalypse,
when I think about the apocalypse,
I think of media,
yours,
volcanoes,
the classics,
you know the ocean dying of like just
cataclysms right,
right.
But really it's like more like absurdity
starts avalanching into time to the
point where things start happening so
quickly that we can't even catch up.
Like now we gotta deal with the fact
there's a fucking tesla infinitely
flying through space.
If it slams into a spaceship that's
coming to visit us,
fucking a man.
Could you imagine it was like the alien
overlord.
So like they're finally ready,
let us visit and they come in at light
speed and then the moment they read
merged from lightspeed,
Tesla comes through the windshield,
hits him right in the face,
takes the head off the emperor and it's
just fucked.
Just explosions.
Just like in Star Wars.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Laura dern is at the wheel holding on or
turn around.
That's what happened in the new star
wars movie.
Spoiler alert.
Remember when they hit warp speed,
they went right through that one jet or
that one.
Yeah,
that's,
that's probably going to happen,
dude.
Or it hits a meaty or it hits a
meteorite that wasn't going to hit earth
and then knocked the trajectory so that
it does.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
there's,
there is now.
Elon musk kills us all when this stupid
fucking car flying through space.
She has his fucking car out.
Just grazes and asteroid clink and it
just,
yeah,
right towards La.
Yeah.
We don't know,
man.
It hits the laugh factory that's been
the center.
That's the fucking main place.
It smashes.
Make God laugh.
Yeah.
It's two side of 18 semis and it hits
the laugh factory.
No one can hear.
No one can hear it,
so it's so loud.
Everyone's ears explode,
please.
No.
If you're nowhere near it,
your ears explode.
If you in Kansas,
if your ears explode from the impact
you're never hearing ever again.
Ever.
No one within up
5,000
mile radius ever hears again.
People in The Bahamas,
like what?
What?
What was that?
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Hey Z,
the earth rings for a million years.
That's fucking crazy.
They sent,
when the earth got hit by that one that
hit the Yucatan 65 million years ago,
it rang for a million years just to
drown.
Just like it got cracked like a gong for
a million years do.
That's fucking crazy.
You ever heard the descriptions of how
deep they think that thing was in the
earth within the first second of impact?
No.
It's something bananas like a miles deep
into the earth within the first second
of impact.
That's how big that thing was called
Manhattan size chunk.
Yeah,
man.
I love that because that's reality.
Isn't that funny?
That's the funny thing about existing on
the planet is because everybody walks
around imagining that the world that
we're living in is permanent,
permanent and stable and not just our
world aren't just society,
but your own life.
Like people walk around through their
own fucking life.
This is the thing I was thinking about
that uh,
that terrible.
It keeps happening but the Amtrak train
crash.
Yeah.
Cause it's like when you think about
that you're just going to work.
Why do you use it?
Here's the thing that disturbed me the
most,
and this disturbed me a lot lately.
This is a real issue.
People that were on the left were saying
that they were happy that it happened,
that God had done something to kill
these politicians because there was a
lot of right wing.
Oh yeah.
G O p people that were on his Amtrak
thing.
Like could you imagine just saying that,
not,
not only thinking it,
but saying it on twitter,
like you're so confident.
Show your righteous with your desire to
have strangers dead in a horrible
fucking train accident.
Yeah.
Like somebody died in that accident and
they're like,
great.
Going to herb and someone's Dad's dead.
Yeah.
Right.
Someone's mom be of was a male or female
at died,
but someone's mom dead.
Someone's sister dead look good.
Good riddance them.
God had a plan for them.
Fuck down.
Like,
cause they're on the other team.
Yeah.
Dude,
that shit does terrifying.
That shit's really sad.
But it never used to be the left.
That's what's the scariest thing to me.
The left was never like advocating
violence.
They were the exact opposite during the
hit,
the,
the Vietnam War,
they were the hippies.
They were the people that wanted to
bring the troops home.
They're the people that didn't want war.
They didn't want violence.
They didn't want to hate.
They denounce tate.
Now they're,
they're like,
they're like talking about violence
being the answer.
I see certain certain political
movements.
I punch a Nazi.
I saw a term on reddit that I liked a
lot called liberal baptist.
Have you heard of this?
So basically the idea is like a,
you know,
like in fundamentalism of any sort
really.
Like the idea is when you're saying that
you're religious,
it's you're,
you're not really interested in another
person's soul or saving another person.
What you're interested in doing is
creating an ethical hierarchy that you
can dominate by being at the top of the
ethical hierarchy.
Right.
So what you're running into with this
that you're talking about is people who
don't really seem so concerned with how
society is supposed to be as much as
using their refined system that they've
come up with,
which is like,
they call it being woke or,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
it's this rough,
crazy,
it's hard to even keep up with it,
but they use it to try to dominate the
people around them by making you scared
to speak your mind.
Because the idea is it's like,
you know,
like I,
one of Mike the guests on my podcast
that I get fucking yelled at more than
anybody else for having on Jordan
Peterson that really pissed a lot of
people after I had him on my podcast
because they feel they misunderstand him
and they think that Jordan Peterson
hates a transgendered people,
I think.
Or they think that he's a,
uh,
I think that he's,
they think that he's like,
all right,
they think that he's like some kind of
outright spokesman.
And the truth of the matter is I don't,
I don't fully know all of Georgia,
the spectrum of Jordan Peterson's views
on things because it would take me a
very long time to do that.
I know he's fucking smart.
I know it was really cool for him to
call my podcasts and I know we had a
really great conversation that didn't
really talk about that stuff,
but it didn't fit the narrative that
they want.
The narrative that they want is that
he's a hateful person and then he hates
transgender people and that he's a bigot
and then he's just right wing outrights
poster boy,
but it's not real.
The problem is people aren't willing to
adjust that once they stand on that
stance,
once they have that position that this
is,
I'm left disguise right way and he's a
pig,
he's ruining things like that.
They just make up their mind.
But can it,
can we throw it,
let me add one thing to this.
Imagine this.
Imagine Jordan Peterson and I don't
honestly,
I don't know,
but just imagine there is a piece of him
that doesn't for whatever reason,
like it he,
I don't know.
I'm,
again,
I'm not saying this as an I have no,
I'm not implying it either.
I'm just saying imagine fucking short
Jordan Peterson.
I don't know.
I'm trying to think of some offensive
thing that he just imagined he had some
piece of him that was definitely
politically not correct.
Right,
okay.
That doesn't mean that all the other
shitty saying is invalidated by some
piece of him cause people are made up of
lots of different pieces.
Well that's basically in a way,
I'm not categorizing Jordan Peterson the
way you categorize descartes,
but that's what he was saying.
Right.
That with great people,
they all also have,
what was the word?
He used a not great sin but great.
What was the word?
He used to remember the word,
the expression.
He ain't got shit.
They've got shit gun shit.
Yeah,
the great flaws as well as,
and I this,
this,
this devices.
That's what he said.
This is to me where the big fucking
problem is,
is that people have lost the ability to
be nuanced and people if and,
and that to me is where things are
really fucked up right now,
which is like you were throwing the baby
out with the bath water.
And I'm not saying like,
oh,
let's give a platform to people who have
like hate speech hate.
Yeah.
But,
but the idea that we have gotten to the
point now where just like free balling
and throwing around ideas,
just like we've done all over the place
here,
I guarantee you when I look at twitter,
there's going to be at least like five
people being like you fucking piece of
shit.
Only because like I'm throwing around
ideas because my hope is through that
process,
I'm going to get closer to the truth and
I'm going to be able to look at myself
like what you said about the cock,
the coke boy.
You know what I mean?
I liked it because you're right.
And I like what you did,
even though his comedic is funny.
You're right,
dude.
Why am I giving that guy a hard fucking
tax you're going to do?
He can't not be born a cookson.
Right?
It's,
he's like you can't change his birth and
his who he is he doing?
So he taking over countries in Africa.
I know he's making cute shirts and he's
banging a hot woman yet.
Hello.
I'd so that's to that.
But I liked,
I liked that having these kinds of
interactions with friends because it
helps me adjust even though I don't have
any real animosity for the koch brother
from that kind of thing.
I can look at my own fucking pattern and
be like,
whoa shit.
Yeah,
that's like a,
that's something to think about cause I
like,
I could be more compassionate there.
So my point is what,
what,
what ends up happening and what leads to
someone who started off being
[inaudible],
who's a,
who considers themselves part of a
group.
There was true that's trying to stop
war.
That spawned the hippie movement and now
they're like thankful that a train
accident happened.
That is a result of gradually shutting
down their ability to understand that a
human is much more than just one fucking
thing.
Jeff sessions is not just an anti
marijuana person.
Jeff sessions is probably an elephant,
an elephant as sweet at that and a
person who's got a lot of love in him
and he's done a lot of good things for a
lot of people,
but also he's got the worst fucking
concept of what marijuana is and that
sucks.
But that doesn't invalidate any of the
love he's expressed throughout his life.
And this is unbearable for some people
to deal with because we want a darth
vader.
Well,
it's because we are inclined to
gravitate towards tribalism.
It is a part of being human being.
It's always going to be a part.
It's the same reason why those
egyptologists were rejecting these ideas
from John Anthony West.
Robert Schoch cause they weren't a part
of the tribe and these new people coming
in with some shit that they didn't
figure it out on their own.
There's a thing that people do on,
whether it's male versus female.
You're seeing a lot of this when it
comes to this me too stuff.
One of the weirdest things that happens
is that you start to getting this divide
where the men are men and the women and
the women in the matter of the men.
Even people that are non offenders and
and non victims.
They shore up on teams and yes,
it's good that people are being exposed
for doing bad things to people,
but it's also very dangerous for us to
just be men and women be on opposite
teams.
We're humans,
right?
We're supposed to be nice to each other.
It's,
it goes back to what we were talking
about earlier.
We,
we don't say that enough.
I really don't think we say it enough.
I really think we need to,
it needs,
it should be reinforced and it sounds
like,
oh,
it's a fucking growth thing.
That's your advice,
Bro.
Be Nice to each other.
Yes,
it is.
My advice.
It's not my only advice.
I think you should also get your shit
together.
I think you should have some fucking
discipline.
I think you should eat right.
I think she'd do a lot of things.
You should read books,
they should pay attention.
I think he's tried to educate yourself.
I think he's tried to be aware about
objectivity and tribalism.
Where are the influence.
But I also think it would be really nice
if we all just agreed to be nicer to
each other and just have it as a
conversation that the country has and
then ultimately the world has.
But that list of things you just gave
before that.
Yeah,
I think that all fits into the category
of being kind to yourself.
And I think that the way you're going to
learn to be nice to other people is by
learning how to be kinder to yourself
and being kind to yourself means
treating your body better.
And that's loving yourself.
And like this is actually one of the
things this Guy Jack Kornfield taught
me,
which I like a lot cause I was talking
to him about,
man,
you know I want to fucking get in shape
and like I feel bad cause I want to be
more in shape.
And he's like,
okay,
but the way you're talking about it,
you're hating yourself right now.
Yeah.
Don't get in shape because you hate who
you are.
Get in shape because you love yourself
enough to want to feel better and to
what?
So saying that it changes the way I'm
looking at it.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you just saying that I'm like,
yeah,
all right.
Yeah,
don't hate your body loving by getting
it healthy and then by loving you,
that's loving your site changes the
intention around from like,
I'm going to destroy my fall myself and
replace it with a better self.
It's like I'm going to love this being I
am right now and the way I'm going to do
that is by,
you know what?
I don't need to have five beers a night.
You know?
I don't need to pour the booze into the
thing every night as much as I have
been.
I don't need to smoke cigarettes or I
don't eat whatever the thing is.
And that attitude of like,
I'm not doing this because I am not
doing this because I hate myself.
It's just this is a different ways of me
too,
for me to express love into my own
world.
And then from that it radiates out.
That's what you did.
I mean that's what you do is like part
of what appeals I think.
And and you that appeals to people is
that you're sort of radiating this like
way of being that offers a lot of people
a sense of like,
oh shit,
I could probably do that.
And it draws people in.
So this kindness that you're talking
about,
it's contagious.
Yes,
it is contagious and it should be,
and it's our cultures operate on the
momentum of the people that are in them.
Right?
Nazi Germany is a good example.
So it was Denmark,
so it was Norway.
I mean it was really interesting
cultures that are very different from
other cultures.
China's very different from a Ethiopia.
I mean we vary widely in the way we
behave and I think there's a bunch of
different styles of being a person.
And I think the problem is,
and this is a problem
that I had as a young man,
I had an ultra competitive issue.
I was competitive with my friends,
I was competitive with other men.
I was competitive.
I would shit on people that I didn't
know.
Look at this fucking loser,
you know,
like it's a natural thing that young men
go through.
And it took me until I was probably in
my early twenties till I realized how
toxic that was.
And I moved myself out of it and instead
started celebrating people around me.
I changed my vibe because I,
I was very flawed as a young men,
but also super hyper self critical.
So my hyper self critical,
I always wanted to be a better version
of myself,
but,
and I would,
I wouldn't do it the right way.
Like it was Jack Cornfield's idea.
Who's,
who is it?
Cornfield Jack Cornfield's idea.
I didn't do it the right way.
I didn't do it his way.
I did it the way that a barely educated
21 year old man who's mostly just read
books on a combat sports and fighting
philosophy in psychology.
I have a very limited amount of
information in my head,
but I realized that there was some flaws
in the way I was thinking and I realized
I was spending all this energy getting
mad at people that I didn't know,
hating people that had things that I
didn't have and I really,
I was sitting around thinking about this
once and it was as I was becoming more
successful as a martial artist,
I was realizing that one of the things
that was holding me back before was my
mind.
And it wasn't just my physical talent,
my skills,
which also got better,
but it was also that I had a better way
of approaching competition that I had
when I was younger because it didn't
carry as much anxiety.
I was,
I was still anxious,
but less anxiety because I was more at
peace with being around all these
different people and stuff.
Fuck this guy who's this fucking guy.
I changed my strategy and it changed who
I am and then as I got into comedy,
I was alleviated by the actual real
threat of competition,
which greatly relaxed to me.
It was a giant weight lifted off my
back,
but that carried a little bit of that.
In the early days of stand up,
I would look at other comedians like,
fuck this guy.
I get jealous of guys that were doing
successful I that we're doing well
rather that we're successful.
I got jealous of guys who were funnier
than me,
like,
why is he fucking funnier than me?
It was,
it was a stupid thought process and it
took me till I was like,
you know,
like 2123 I started realizing like I got
to snap out of this.
This is unhealthy.
Like I'm wasting this energy where it
should be concentrating on positive
things.
So I just started supporting my friends.
I started being like a more
complimentary person.
I started,
I just went out of my way to just be
nicer to people,
be nicer to people,
not because they could do something for
me,
just to be nice,
like it feels good to be nice and I just
slowly cultivated a better philosophy
and it took me a while,
man.
It took me until I was in my twenties
till I really like,
as I was like getting closer to 30 is
when I started really getting good at it
with comedy,
you know,
like bringing comedians on the road.
Helping people.
Yeah.
That's fostering other career.
Telling kids that were like seven years
before,
you know,
behind me like they were,
they started out seven years after me.
I'm at a seven years ahead of you.
You can do this.
Anybody can do this,
right?
Just do it.
And if you fuck up,
learn from that fuck up.
Get better.
This is,
this is the thing that you can do.
You're a funny person,
right?
You're just,
all you have to do is just keep doing
this and you're gonna.
You already made it.
Yeah.
No,
this is the,
so this thing that you're talking about,
the thing that I,
that the Rom Dass people teach me,
which is invaluable and it to me and it
really inspires you,
is that they talk about Ron does his
guru,
neem Karoli Baba and how when he was
teaching,
he never said,
here's what this is going to do for you.
Right?
He was never like,
this is why this is how it's going to
help you.
He was always saying,
here's how this is going to help the
people in your life.
And so the moment you make that little
shift where working on yourself as it's
called,
is not about doing something so that you
can fucking have a fucking six pack and
played.
But the moment you start doing our fun
in a cow and ride a horse,
shaving,
shaving your stomach,
but,
but the moment you start fucking doing
this stuff because you know that it's
going to directly help the people around
you in ways you can't even imagine.
Like you don't even know yet because
there's going to be a moment in every
single person's life where someone comes
up to you who is in a lot of trouble and
they need help and it might not be
money,
it might not.
It might just be something you could say
to them.
It might just be something you need to
be lucid in that moment and because
you've been like,
you know,
not paying attention and you're blurry
and you're angry and you're fucking shut
down that you're not even going to see
that person.
Right.
That person is going to just be another
face in the crowd that you don't even
see.
But that's the whole point is like this
practice your practice.
It ends up helping so many fucking
people and if you want to get excited
about something,
at least for me,
what makes,
it's really kind of difficult for me to
get super excited over like I don't
know,
some kind of like thing that's like,
and it give me an extra thing.
It's way less exciting than to think
that like,
Shit,
man,
if I can be more calm and more
connected,
then the next time around somebody I
love and get angry,
I'm not going to hurt them because I'm
learning how to not react to my own
bullshit.
Right.
You know,
you're getting better at live.
Yeah.
And it's through trial and error.
I mean,
that is a trial error,
honesty.
And you also have to realize that we're
not all coming from the same starting
block.
You know?
Right.
Some people came from uh,
abusive childhoods.
Some people came from super supportive
and loving childhood.
Some people were spoiled as children and
that's what they're,
they're the people that struggle the
most.
Sometimes you see in kids that grow up
in like really rich families where the
pee pee parents weren't hands on.
They're so disconnected.
Right.
You feel really weird and titled and
they have a very distorted version of
the future.
And those people,
it's very hard.
It's very hard to adjust from a place of
bounty,
right.
To a place of struggle and success and
in in,
you know,
self realization almost more difficult
for some of those people.
Compassion look neat growing up as a
person who didn't have money,
you know,
and,
and thinking as when I was a child,
when my family was on welfare,
thinking I still can remember at least I
have a,
an idea of a memory of us drinking
powdered milk.
I remember that.
I remember being really embarrassed if
people would come over our house.
We had powdered milk,
we are poor,
you know,
and that memory of being a young man,
of being a struggling young comedian,
doing a bunch of odd jobs,
trying to make it like this,
this real hunger and worry.
I remember one of the most embarrassing
moments of my young life,
um,
I had this thing fall out.
It was like some management company was
interested in me and they were like a
music management company and they were
thinking about branching off into
comedians and guy was talking to me
about it and it was falling apart and I
was driving with my girlfriend and I was
21 and the whole thing was so
frustrating to me that I just started
crying,
tears rolling.
And I remember she looked over and she's
like,
are you crying?
I was like,
yeah,
fuck yeah.
And she's like,
oh.
Like she was like mocking the fact that
I was crying.
She couldn't help herself,
you know,
she was same age,
we're both at 21 we were both kids,
you know,
and she just thought it was a bitch
move.
Just be crying about being frustrated
about your career.
And I remember being so embarrassed,
like,
why did I,
why did I let that out to her?
Like,
why did I let that out in public at this
frustration of not knowing where the
future lies,
but that frustration and that hunger of
like wanting to figure out a way to get
out of this cycle of work in shitty jobs
and figure out how to do something that
I actually love doing.
Like be a comic that,
that burning hunger cause you don't have
shit.
That's where it all comes from.
Would you don't know where the fuck
you're going to pay your rent.
You do.
You do not have an escape route.
There's no net.
You got to figure this fucking thing out
man and you're not figuring it out right
now.
Right now it's fallen apart and nobody,
nobody thinks you're any good.
You can't get booked like fuck.
You're trying to figure out what's the
next job.
You're going to get it so you could feed
yourself.
We tried to figure out this weird thing
that nobody could really tell you how to
do,
you know,
but then going through that struggle,
that is everything,
but people need to hear that you went
through it too.
They need to hear that,
that during the dark days where it
doesn't seem like it's ever going to
work out,
are you alive?
Can you see?
Can you talk?
Can you think get better,
get better,
whatever you're doing,
skip better so you suck at it.
Now everybody sucks at everything when
they first start.
That's the whole thing about getting
good at something,
but if you love it and you're really
honest,
don't lie to yourself.
Don't lie to yourself.
Look at it for what it is.
Look at it for what it is and work on
it.
Whatever the fuck it is,
whether it's writing books or make you
sick or composing a computer code,
whatever the fuck you want to do.
If you suck at it,
get better.
But look at it for what it is.
Look at it for really what it is and
that's one of our biggest problems.
One of our biggest problems is that
people have a really hard time looking
at things for what they are if they're
not flattering.
That's right.
Yeah.
Do you want to think,
oh fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy goes a pussy now that guy,
it shot a fucking rocket into space with
a car on it.
Okay.
And he did it with his mind.
He figured out how to make these
calculations.
You figured out how to make enough money
so he could shoot a car in a space.
If you don't respect that,
it's digging tunnels under La.
They'll let them dig tunnels.
There's an earthquake ridden area and
this motherfucker is digging holes in
the ground.
We're worried about fracking,
but we're like Eli musk got it.
He said it's not going to cause an
earthquake.
It's not going to cause an earthquake.
Yeah,
we're worried about people fracking.
We're not worried about Elon musk
turning our fucking city into Swiss
cheese.
Yeah,
but you know,
man,
the thing is is that the guy you're
make,
you're like creating an image of the guy
was like Fuck Elan.
Good.
That guy is real real.
That's real.
That's me.
I was 21 right.
Can you felt like you can quit and you
felt like shit.
That's the important thing is like that.
That's all coming from feeling like
shit.
And when you get around somebody who's
acting like that,
if you've looked into yourself enough to
see where you feel like shit and then
you get around somebody and you realize
like,
oh this person is like being a complete
fucking cunt to me right now feels like
shit.
And this is the,
I went to see the Dalai Lama and Anaheim
and who you're partnering with Ron Doss.
The Dalai Lama.
Wow.
This is like not parting with it.
I would love to party with a fucking
Dalai Lama.
I would love that.
I'm really might nullify my cock if I
got a chance to party with the Dalai
Lama space forever.
It's another thing to talk to.
I'd do.
I'd love to be around that guy man.
Just cause like when he was like so far
down in this massive place,
this little guy,
you could feel his,
the energy rushing off of this guy into
the room.
It will be trippin maybe.
But anyway.
But anyway,
the thing that he said that stuck with
me as he's like,
one of the things he says is so simple
and it reminds me what you're saying now
is he said you can always be kinder.
And then the other thing he said,
and it sounds so simple,
but really people don't realize that you
can always be kinder at any moment.
And then the other thing he said is if
someone's being unkind to you,
it's not them being unkind to you.
It's an echo,
is what he said.
Like it's literally an echo of the
unkindness people being cruel to them
throughout their lives and that shit is
bouncing off of them like sound.
It's bouncing onto you.
And so when you get around someone who's
like being a shit,
what you're really experiencing is that
there you're a lot of sorrow from a lot
of places you don't know.
And that doesn't mean you're supposed to
lay back and let them like spit on you
or be a shithead to you or whatever.
But it also,
it helps you find a little bit of
compassion,
right?
That's just just so you can be with that
person and let them be what they are
without adding more suffering to it.
Right?
Which only compounds
this situation.
Well,
you have to learn how people are
responding to that behavior too and,
and adjust accordingly.
Get and do the hard work and look at
yourself.
And when people get super self
indulgent,
one of the things that they do is they
don't think about how other people are
experiencing them.
Right?
Like if you're around people like
fucking the fucking worse look always
fucking happens to me.
It's safety every day at work.
Fucking boss knows it wasn't.
Mike did put in the work.
I put fucking 65 70% of the work.
Yes.
Whoa.
Does she leave?
Yeah,
those people are gross.
You're like,
I gotta go,
man.
I can't.
When people started go,
which don't do,
what is the worst thing people do to
you?
When we were,
what should I do?
What did the should do?
Metal neutral advice and needs.
Invites.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
No,
you don't.
You dust sound.
What's going on?
You want me to talk about you?
You're making me focus on you 100%
you're not asking me for help for
yourself.
You're not helping yourself at all.
What you're doing is making me
concentrate on you are,
bro.
Fuck,
I'm really feeling depressed right now.
Well,
do something about it.
I'm not saying don't reach out to your
friends,
but I'm saying you got to do something
to man.
You can't just always talk about your
problems.
Talk about my problems.
You didn't want to hear him because
that's all you talk about.
What's your whole life?
A problem,
right?
Jesus Christ.
Maybe that's the way you're thinking.
Maybe this is the way you're behaving.
We mapped out your life or am I saying
that you shouldn't be there for your
friends when issues arise and there's a,
certainly all of our friends are super
supportive.
We've all gone through some weird shit
in our lives.
We've all been super supportive,
but if I'm super supportive to you,
I know you're super supportive to
yourself.
Yeah,
I know you're working on yourself too,
right?
Not just relying on me.
They broke.
What should I do today,
which I do tomorrow?
What are you thinking?
If you could sit down here with me for a
few hours and map out my future roadway
pressured cause it's just fucking hard
out there for me bro.
You gotta do shit.
Don't fucking bullshit dude.
You're fucking,
you know man.
Fuck you had a good headstart.
You're white guard from North Carolina.
Fuck you dude.
It's what it is man.
Come up these toxic excuses for why
their life is shit without ever looking
inward.
And they'd want you to admit your
privilege and admit your fucking
advantages bro.
Hello you Duncan [inaudible] it was
easier for you.
The truth for me.
But,
but the question is like,
cause I know exactly what you're talking
about and I know that person and I know
when I run into that with that is
there's a part of me that,
and I like what I know sometimes you
just have to put someone you have to
like avoid their presence.
So you gonna say put them on blast.
I thought you were going,
can I put them on blast?
No,
cause it doesn't work.
That doesn't work.
But maybe it does for you.
I don't know,
but it does put,
there's a,
they just get mad at you,
right?
So,
but there is a thing of like I,
and this is where I might just be
fucking naive or crazy or one toke over
the line,
sweet.
But I believe that with any body that
you're around,
if you've cultivated love,
like if you can really love them,
even in the midst of that cyclone of
bullshit that you're talking about,
if you could look through the cyclone
right into their soul,
like into what they are that's love and
see that and love it,
then the psych clonal start calming down
a little bit right in front of you.
I think it's possible.
I think it's possible that if,
and this is why I think it's fucking
worth figuring out a way to cultivate
this shit that you're talking about so
that when you get around a Turd cycline
like that,
you know that you,
you actually,
you become potentially the person who
like not by giving them money or giving
them advice,
but just by giving them love and letting
them be this cyclone of shit for a
second and loving it for real.
You might be the thing that,
that just like musk's fucking tesla hits
the media or in sends it into earth,
you might be the thing that dings the
media or of their life and prevents the
catastrophe that they were spinning
towards.
It's entirely possible,
but it's also entirely possible that
like most things in life,
you need a lot of various elements.
You don't just need one person,
right,
that you cling to.
You mean to look at humanity as a whole.
You need to seek inspiration in the
great work of others and you need to
look at yourself in a way that you think
maybe perhaps other people look at you.
Right.
And that is something that a lot of
people don't do.
And that lack of introspection and self
critical thinking is one of the reasons
why people don't change.
Right.
Cause they don't adjust.
Like you're not the guy you were 10
years ago.
I've known you for a long time.
You're a better version because you've
adjusted.
Yeah.
I mean not that you were bad then.
I love you back then you were awesome.
But you're,
you're a more together,
more philosophical,
more at ease with yourself person than
you were 10 15 years ago.
Yeah.
Like when we were living together and I,
we lived together when you were at a
down spot.
You're a totally different human now.
Yeah.
Cool.
And you are begin.
And that's the thing,
man.
Because you are like in those moments
when you were like,
when we're riding in my fucking mini
cooper and I'm trying to listen to
Elliot Smith and you know,
I'm depressed
and you're like,
dude,
what are you listening to?
What the fuck you listening to you?
I'll never forget that.
And I'll tell you,
man,
in my head,
I'm like,
what a Dick was definitely being the
day.
Yeah.
But,
but,
but that what,
what that was was like though,
it was what you were doing is helping
me,
like get out of that vibration that I
was,
you were wallowing in it.
Yes.
And I needed in it.
And I didn't in those moments when you
were doing that shit,
I was like in my head resisting.
And I'm like,
you know,
but that's the other thing,
when you decide to help somebody and
that way you can't expect it's going to,
there's shift or change.
It's going to happen instantaneously.
But because of that,
I still to this day when I put on Elliot
Smith,
I think at that moment,
man,
I still,
they hear your voice in my head going to
go,
he it,
what are you doing?
Because you know what I mean?
Because,
because,
and I'll tell you why man.
Because sometimes when you can listen to
Elliot Smith and not be wallowing and
it's just really pretty and sweet,
but don't listen to that shit if you're
wallowing because it's like,
it's,
yeah.
Oh,
won't feed the wallet.
Don't feed the wall.
Yeah.
Don't feed that wallowing spirit inside
of you.
Don't.
You don't need to feel that everybody
experiences loss and everybody
experiences bad moments.
You just going to you,
you never going to get life perfect.
Right?
So during these bad moments,
what you got to realize is just
accepted.
Feel it,
get through it.
Realize it's a journey that you're going
to get through.
But yeah,
realize that there's better ways to
navigate it.
Then some and some ways are really bad.
The is a really bad way to navigate it
and started doing heroin and start
fucking listen to Elliot Smith ago
holding a knife over your stomach in the
middle of your fucking bedroom going,
fuck it man.
Fuck it,
man.
I can't do that.
You can't do that.
Well,
you can look him,
but it's not,
it's not the healthiest way to go.
That's going to give people around you
and you yourself the most joy.
It's not necessarily selfish,
it's self indulgent for sure.
I don't necessarily think it's selfish.
I think it's just,
it's,
it's a pattern of behavior that you can
get trapped in.
Yeah.
And I think we've all been in bad
situations where you just feel like shit
like you,
you get in a pattern of behavior and you
feel trapped,
but you gotta,
you gotta learn from other people who've
been through those patterns and learn
from your own experiences getting
through pat.
Yeah.
Cause you get you,
well that's the thing man.
It's like when you get around someone,
he's like a teacher figure.
Like you early,
you get around somebody know that he was
like really doing it from love and not
trying to fucking like fuck with you
because that's,
that can happen the worst or be superior
to you or,
right,
right.
Pull you down and yeah.
Yeah.
You down when you get around somebody
who's like doing it out of,
out of love.
There is such a massive difference in,
in the,
in the way that feels and,
and what they do quite often or what a
lot of my teachers do,
which is really fucking cool because
like in the same way you've seen me kind
of go shift,
you know,
a lot of my teachers from the Rom dies
camp like in the beginning when I was
actively trying to offend them because
that was what I would try to do.
It's like it'd be funny not be funny
cause I was thinking if I can offend
these people about the practice,
they're teaching me and they're like,
hey,
you can't say that or that's blasphemy
or anything like that.
Then I know to get the fuck out of there
cause it's like,
you know what I mean?
Because you were,
you were calculated.
Fuck yeah.
Is calculated with one.
It was one of my teachers.
Ragu,
his name's Ragu.
Like the spaghetti sauce.
It means a different thing in the,
it does change your name Bro.
It's a,
my name's spaghettios but listen bro,
don't think about it like that.
And my master spaghettios taught me,
what the fuck did you just,
he's amazing.
He's amazing.
And like in the same sauce the same way
you're doing that with the garlic,
the same way you're doing that with him.
I would try to do that with like their
teachers and,
and,
but,
and I would try to do that too because I
was like,
fuck it.
If they get mad at me right then I know
then who cares if there's a thing where
I don't like blasphemy,
I don't like the idea.
I can blast fee,
man,
that freaks me the fuck out.
But it was like when named Karoli Baba,
you know,
they tell me these stories and I'd be
like,
you know,
I just don't,
I just don't really believe that man.
Like I don't know if that it's,
I don't know if I believed that shit.
And rog you,
I still remember saying that walking in
this at the retreat with him in Hawaii
and he gets a big smile on his face.
He's like,
yeah,
I don't blame you for not believing in
it.
It's like,
Whoa,
cool man,
this is fucking cool.
And it's that.
That's the,
so when you get around a real teacher,
what I'm saying is the place that you're
at,
they let you be there,
but they're not like in the sense that
they're letting you do the pattern that
you're in.
But by allowing that to happen in its
own way and then adding to it the
intention of like,
I think I'm going to help you grow here.
That's when you really start changing.
Not when someone's like you,
when you were in the car and listen to
Elliot Smith and you were fucking
recognizing in me a lot of sadness and a
lot of fucked up Nez.
You weren't scolding me,
dude,
you are giving me love.
But the way you were giving me what I
love was by making fun of me in this
really sweet way.
And it worked.
You know what I mean?
It was,
it was.
So that's the thing.
That's what a real teacher does.
And that's why it's like,
you know,
it took to learn how to get to that spot
is one of the most important things you
could do.
Also from a selfish standpoint,
um,
when you have a good friend that is all
sudden looking for a place to live and
then they could live with you,
it's cool,
it's far right.
But it also feels really good to help
some money to help somebody that you
love and you really care about.
So I mean,
I don't even think I thought about it
for three seconds.
When you called me up and you were in a
hotel room,
I go,
dude,
come live with me.
Yeah,
it was like instantly Dunkin's live with
me instantly.
I was like,
she got a place to live,
dude.
You never have to worry about having a
place to live.
I wanted you to,
you know,
and also you were,
I've had a lot of people that have
offered the tank to anytime you want,
come on by,
you can use tank.
You were the only guy who use it on a
regular basis.
Like when it tate live with me.
He didn't touch that fucking crazy
thing.
He's like,
fuck this.
He might've gotten in there once,
I don't know,
but that was not his style at the time,
you know?
But you were in there all the time and
you were writing journals and shit.
When you get out of,
then we would talk about it.
You would talk about your inner voyage
when you'd go in that tank and just
think about your life and how you,
you're,
you know,
well what you're doing and what happened
and what went wrong and where were you
to and
just look,
Damn.
The fucking stress of trying to be a
professional comic is it fucks.
You know how I know it fucks you?
Because it fucks me every two years,
every two years when I abandoned my act
and put out a special and I'd have to
write a whole new one and a goddamn
sweating.
Just thinking about it right now,
like Thompson girls gone through that
right now,
our,
he's going through that right now.
That's,
that's the shedding of,
of all you've got.
And then you've got to start from
scratch to fucking terrifying again.
And that's the thing that makes you keep
growing.
The thing that makes you keep growing.
But when you're,
when you haven't had any success,
like when you were in the beginning of
your career and it just hadn't happened
yet,
you're like,
you don't really believe it can happen.
But once you do have it happen,
then you go,
oh,
I see.
Just gotta get through that
dude.
The thing you're talking about with the
comedy,
it's,
it applies to everything.
And it's like the,
it's because what you're talking about,
someone's always telling me,
like if a snake doesn't successfully
shed its skin,
it dies.
And,
and,
and that,
so a person is the same way in the sense
that many of us clean to ways that we
were thinking,
that's who we still are when we're not.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and you have to learn what parts of
yourself you to let go of,
like,
and you have to have the guts to fucking
let go of it.
And Dude,
that is one of the craziest things.
When you really have a thing that you've
become attached to,
for a lot of people,
it's a relationship that sucks.
You end up in a bad relationship,
bad job.
You end up just come attached to some
version of yourself that you just aren't
anymore.
That's not who you are,
right?
You got to let go of that.
You got to let go of it.
And,
and,
and letting go of it is death.
It's a form of death.
It feels like death.
And so people want to avoid it.
And what ends up happening is you run
into people who are just fucking don't
even realize,
did their valets covered in bags from
all these preview.
They're hoarders and they won't let go
of all these things,
all these ways they used to be.
So that's the,
the,
what I,
I've learned is that through this act of
like scanning the south are looking into
this south,
you'll find places where you're stuck,
where you're stuck.
Like for example,
you were saying,
okay,
I get jealous.
I was getting jealous of these people.
I was getting jealous.
Well,
you were stuck there.
That was the plan.
It wasn't just Joe's worse than that.
It was a toxic or it was,
I didn't like them.
Yes.
Mad at them.
Yeah,
you were stuck.
Yeah.
And you are attached and you were like
in that attachment was making you
unhappy,
miserable,
heavy,
heavy.
The feeling is literally not just that
week.
We,
we felt weak.
Well those were really bothered because
all the energy that's being put in,
they carry no,
in my judgment of myself.
Yeah.
Not,
not weak,
like tired,
like didn't have the energy week.
Like,
Oh,
you bitch,
you're just jealous.
That's you.
That's you now.
Yeah.
I know man.
And the,
these are like,
you know,
like when I'm fuck dude,
when you get a really bad muscle spasm
and then you go to a misuse and that,
that moment when the thing finally gives
way and you're like,
oh,
that place in your back that hurts so
bad suddenly just feels like you're back
again.
And you're like,
ah.
Well the,
the,
uh,
the same thing happens with suffering.
So the suffering and a lot of people's
lives,
they're repeating suffering.
That's a karmic muscle spasm.
And,
and it's like,
until you literally push into it and the
same way you get rid of a muscle spasm,
it fucking hurts man.
Until you like get the blood flow going
back into that place and really fucking
go deep into why do I get jealous?
You know,
for me,
the thing I just figured out or that's
haunted me,
it's just jealousy in relationships.
It's like,
why do I do this?
What is this?
This is just like you're saying it's
weak.
It's not a good look.
I don't like it.
And it's indulgent.
Like while you're doing it,
you realize it's gross.
Yes.
And You keep doing it.
And you're like,
oh my God,
I'm being a bitch and I'm gonna keep
going.
You fucking texted him first.
Yes.
That Joe,
that it's so humiliating and so
embarrassing and so fucked up and so
brutal to the person you're with.
So like that thing I figured,
I figured out a lat,
am I say let it go?
Oh,
it's the illusion.
I don't,
not putting out there that you can
conquer,
you know,
eternally parts of your identity or
whatever.
But I've been able to let that go and
that feeling of really being able to let
it go,
wow,
man,
that's,
to me,
that's one of those monumental things
when you can start dropping these things
and it's different for everybody.
Everybody's got their own fucking muscle
spasm,
but you'll know what it is.
You know what,
any people listening to it right now,
you know what it fucking is.
We are incredibly,
uh,
so we,
we are incredibly susceptible to
patterns incredibly.
So.
Yeah.
And if you have a pattern of weakness
and you accept it over and over again,
it can define you and you have to be
really careful that he got it.
Well,
yeah.
And but in,
what's the beauty of it though,
is the very fucking thing that's hurting
you like that.
It's also simultaneously the thing
that's like your,
it's your fuel for improvement.
Yeah.
It's like you're turning your trap.
This is such a cheesy thing that I
thought I said that I'm,
that I'm never going to like make it a
blog post or anything,
so I forget me if I did think about
this.
It's turning your trap into a
trampoline.
It's like you find this fucking,
you have a self help speaker.
I need,
see right now in a theater,
I know that's like a big screen behind
you.
It's trying your tread happen.
I knew that's why he has it.
I deserved to be made fun of for it and
I'm not going to ever use that in a book
or in a blog post or anything,
but I really do like the concept of like
finding the place you're stuck and
realizing that that's not a place you
should avert your eyes from,
but in fact more than likely that's a
door,
right?
That's a fucking door.
And you can go through that door into a
whole new existence where you're no
longer horrified by yourself and that
that is really exciting.
It's really fucking wonderful moment.
You know,
not just in comedy,
but I think in anything
it's always a powerful thing to improve.
It's a,
that's one of the things that's good
about doing things that you're not good
at.
Um,
is it,
you get the opportunity to see what
happens when you work at something and
then you improve.
And I think that applies to everything.
I think if you learn how to play a game,
you get really good at a game.
I think that figuring things out in your
mind how to get good at this game
applies to life.
I think there's a,
you could get caught up in a game where
like chess or whatever it is becomes
your whole life and then it's almost too
much.
Right?
But you can also use things like chess
or a lot of different things.
Like we have,
people have a heavy prejudice against
video games,
but this,
it's been absolutely proven that video
games can enhance many aspects of the
way people think and problem solve.
It's been proven.
I mean there's studies don't doing that.
People are doing on it,
but we associate video games with
wasting time slacking off being a loser.
Mimo.
Jamie,
what the fuck were you just telling me
the other day about how much money these
guys make when they're playing twitch?
Yeah.
Thousands of dollars a day,
if not hundreds of thousands a month.
Hundreds of thousands dollars a month
playing fucking video games.
How has being a lawyer better than that?
You fucking asshole.
Is it about making money?
What is it about,
cause these twitch guys got you beat
fuck face.
Yeah.
You're out there just making people get
divorced and raking in the cash.
This guy is shooting aliens on twitch
and it's making it way more.
Yeah,
you're a loser.
Yeah.
Private Gucci shoes.
He's got a diamond crusted grow legs and
he plays video games.
Do you understand how crazy that is?
You're over there working on family law.
Do you watch twitch?
No.
See that's the thing,
man.
You know,
uh,
things to do,
but I don't mind God Z.
I play,
I play a lot of games,
man.
I only have so much time.
I played,
I play pool.
I shoot archery,
dude,
you got to,
first of all,
you got to watch twitch just for just
for the sake of definitely don't.
Just so you know,
for the podcast,
you don't have to,
but you need to look to that.
You could see the how one,
how it sounds when you hear about it.
I remember when I first heard about it,
I'm like that there's an unseen mighty
mouse.
Do it.
It's really entertaining.
Yeah.
And it's really funny and it's like when
you're looking at like the,
the community that forms around these
people and like,
then you realize like,
man,
there really is something really
soothing and addictive about watching.
Dude.
Have you seen that twitch guy who trolls
people and uh,
what's it called?
My space that,
what's that world where,
what?
No,
no,
it's chuck not vr chat.
There's this dude goes into different
video games playing a character and
trolls people inside the games and it's
some of the funniest fucking shit you've
ever seen.
Like he goes into what second life?
He goes into second life somehow makes
it into a,
like a enclave of people playing the
part of bikers in there.
And he goes in there and they're like,
they're acting like bikers.
So they're like,
how'd you get in here?
And he's like,
I don't know,
I'm just,
you know,
I'm here.
He's like,
dad has this very calm voice that like,
you need to get out of here.
And he's like,
I just,
I,
you know,
I'll come,
I'm going to go,
but I'll be back tomorrow.
And they're like,
no,
you will not be back here tomorrow.
You are not coming back.
This is our place.
Or you had to show that.
Can you show that on?
I was looking up second life isn't
allowed on twitch for some reason,
but this,
it's a streamer.
Look up second life are,
this is our place.
I don't know if you can,
if you'll even be able to find it.
So our play suit,
it is the funniest shit.
So there's a video that he recorded.
Then you put it online so people would
watch it and he trolls.
Shit.
Tons of people this way man.
If you find it,
I found a video says extreme angry,
extreme angry ranger for a hell.
Hilarious.
Trolling that.
Probably a second life.
Three fingers.
What can I see it?
I'll know what it is right away.
That's a theme.
I think it's probably him.
But go back and look up.
This is our place biker.
Second life troll and maybe someone on
twitter can help us find it cause it's
like a pretty famous troll video.
But it's like the funniest fucking shit
man.
Like I've watched it a million times.
I'm looking on twitter right now to see
was there ever trolling before the
Internet?
This is it dude.
I think.
I think that's it man.
Second life will shut her down and I
will speak to me.
It's one of them.
What's the one?
So she's talking you have a different
one.
What's the one in that yet as a second
life.
Hold on.
What's that one?
You going to come to a fucking MC
motorcycle club.
He's using.
Yeah.
Abbreviation.
I have a reputation that precedes me.
You can go anywhere and you can mention
my name.
Why am I am famous?
You know what?
Because Heights,
people that be like,
that's not him.
That's amazing though.
What's the one in the lower and the
first suggestion right there.
I was hooked already now that,
anyway,
the point is watching video games is a,
is a fucking blast.
I wish I could finesse.
It's weird.
Look,
watching games is a blast.
I like watching.
That's that guy.
The doctor disrespect.
Yeah.
Um,
there's like,
there's a lot
of things that's interesting.
I like watching people play pool.
I do,
right.
I don't even play golf.
And I like watching people play golf
because they talking or should I do,
what should I do?
Like things going to make it.
Yeah.
I think he's going to fuck up looking at
me.
Sweating.
Yes.
It's fun.
Yeah,
it's fine.
The thing about video games is you can
do it from the first person so you can
look at it from their perspective.
Yeah.
And it's fucking crazy to watch me.
I went to,
I went to the um,
Blizzcon,
you know,
blizzard has the Blizz con like,
like I,
I was lucky enough to get in there,
man.
And I got to watch like a East sports.
I got to watch people playing star craft
and an auditorium and it was awesome and
the energy and there was so fucking
intense.
People were there,
I don't know,
hundreds,
hundreds.
It was like shit,
tons man.
These are like famous players do it.
These are like world renowned Korean
fucking star craft masters in like when
they're there and if you know anything
about starcraft and you see what they're
doing,
it's incredible.
And it's just like,
you know the applause,
the fucking like people are like,
well it's super complex.
So fun to watch.
That's what I'm talking about.
What this people that have these
prejudices about video games,
there's super like video games,
especially like starcraft.
They are super complex.
They require a multilevel thinking.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
you can't fuck,
you can't just play star craft.
Not against those guys.
I mean I've seen you play it for two and
I'm like,
what are you doing?
And moving shit around like what are you
doing?
Like Oh,
I'm setting this up and this is for
later.
Like what?
I know,
like what is this
tried to return to it.
Talk about like feeling old.
Go back to try to play starcraft after a
couple of expansions of come out and
you're just like,
I can't,
what the fuck man,
I have to learn.
You don't have that kind of time.
I don't have that kind of time to like
learn how to do fucking [inaudible]
is again,
I don't want to be,
I liked,
oh my God,
this is that like the o two arena.
It looks at opening ceremonies and soul
for 2014 legal legends.
Oh Wow.
God,
it's a football stadium.
Yeah.
It's like a giant soccer stadium so bad.
Oh my God.
It's filled with people.
That's like 50,000
people there.
Yeah.
That's cool man.
That's insane.
It's so big in Korea.
Huh?
Holy Shit Dude.
All those people look at the size of the
police too.
Why isn't that caught on like that here?
There's what overwatch league,
they just started this week or this
month.
That's in the,
in Burbank.
I liked the old Johnny Carson theater.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
That's cool dude.
When I was,
uh,
addicted to quake,
I would watch demos all the time from
this guy named thresh.
See if you could fine thresh quake.
There was this kid,
God,
I wish I remembered his name.
I think his last name was falling tennis
fong.
There it is.
Dennis Fong,
he was the best.
And while he was playing before he
retired,
he was the best.
Like he was so good that people would
watch his demos and try to emulate his
moves.
And what he would do was he would figure
out a map like absolutely.
So He'd have these one on one duels and
this is another thing that's
surprisingly complex is playing duals
in.
This is quake one that we're looking at
here.
Oh No it's not.
It looks like quick three.
Hold on.
Quick one tournament.
This,
it goes at a new version of it.
Oh No,
it's definitely quick one.
Okay.
So there,
cause you see the shotgun shells and
shit like that.
There's all different stuff.
There's rocket launchers and this didn't
have a rail gun.
The rail gun changed a lot of shit and
quake two.
But the point being that you would have
these strategies because you had a map
and it would all be about controlling
the response.
So all of the items,
well it's a rocket launcher or shotgun
or whatever the fuck it is that you're
picking up.
And the,
the Ammo,
all of it would respond as well as the
health.
So it was all about controlling where
the respawn is,
keeping your health up really high and
then making sure your opponent never
gets any good weapons.
And so they would,
it was really strategic and they chase
each other around the map.
This one dude just fucked everybody up.
I mean,
and he lost a couple of times too when
he was,
you know,
starting out.
But he eventually got to a point where
he was like the Michael,
like the right there,
boom.
He's,
he's that guy.
Boom Jackson.
He knows where you're going.
He's firing rockets down hallways.
He anticipates you're going to be going
down and when you would watch these guys
play it.
See like right there,
that guy was there and he's just waiting
for him.
Boom,
boom.
And he just killed the dude.
And I would watch these guys in these
demos and try to learn from like how
they were maneuvering.
There's another guy called fatality and
he was really good at it and there was
different games that guys would play
too.
There was this game and some guys went
over to unreal and they played unreal
tournament.
It's got the armor st every time it
responds,
he's going to be running back there to
get that armor running back there to get
the shotgun shells,
making sure that his opponent doesn't
have a rocket and you just keep killing
them.
And then when he responds he chased him
down,
kill him again or weaken them.
And then these are fucking really
complex multilevel games.
You have to think in advance and you
have to plan things out and guys would
even have timed things that they would
put in a program so that it would show
on their screen.
Rocket launcher responding and 10
seconds,
nine Aa.
Yeah.
It's crazy how when this came out,
it was so bad ass.
And now it looks so ancient.
It looks weird.
But,
but go to quick.
What does the quake for one,
what does the new quake one quick
tournament,
what does it?
Quake champions and the,
it's called quake champions.
There's one you could play online now.
I think it's called quake champions.
Oh.
Came out last year.
Now Watch this shit arena.
That's what it is.
Quake champions arena.
Is that it?
But look at the fucking graphics now.
But it's the same kind of concept,
right?
So you know this,
this guy is playing a one on one against
someone and there's these crazy maps.
Looks bad ass at was the last time you
played quake forever.
Dude,
I'm terrified.
No daddy got problems.
Like you're like,
watch.
I'm feel crazy dude.
I'm telling you I can't do this.
I used to play this shit for eight,
10 hours a day.
I told you I got a t one line stolen my
fucking house at is so fucking funny
though.
Just nailed him with a real gun.
Yeah,
I was.
I had a real problem.
So,
uh,
I prefer,
archery and a bunch of other things that
I get addicted to,
but I could easily get addicted to this
again.
Yeah.
Is so fun.
Look super shooters.
What?
Oh,
you,
but you don't,
you just don't play them.
Right.
Listen,
if we decided to do that,
would you come and play it here?
Yeah,
of course.
Okay.
What we're thinking about doing is we
have a conference room that I'm thinking
about turning to a land party room.
Oh,
cool.
And have it set up.
We'll set up a quick games and then
we'll,
uh,
maybe we'd host a server and let a
certain amount of people online.
Yeah.
And then we could have what you call
deathmatch outcome with death matches.
Like you have 10 people on a map and
they're all just going crazy and you
respond with all your shit.
Just do that.
But what about,
why don't we pick up a new one like
this,
this fucking game in this game.
[inaudible] battlegrounds.
Battlegrounds.
Yeah.
Man,
this is probably bad at,
I don't want real physics.
I don't want to move around like are
moving around in real life.
That's the thing about quake cause you
move weight quicker than you do in real
life.
It's like you're bouncing and jumping.
You're hitting trampolines and flying
through the air.
Oh Man,
this thing looks pretty cool.
If you'll look,
we think you'd like it cause you hunt
people.
You're hiring someone else and I'm not
even a hundred people bro.
I mean the hunting aliens that can move
faster.
The people with rocket launches you
didn't buy.
Those are quaker.
What about hearthstone?
Joe,
why don't you start playing hearthstone?
You want me to cast spells like you do
have to be naked again.
I like overwatch then cause that's a
little bit more,
yeah,
overwatch is.
That's a third person thing.
This is the one I was explaining the
overwatch league.
This is the viewing of it.
So I specialize.
You can view it,
but I like watching things through
someone's eyes.
That's it.
There you go.
First person who the Rogers.
Hey this looks great.
This looks great.
Yeah.
This is team based.
We should have an overwatch league.
I suck at it.
You know he's good at it as Pemberton
you can get pampered.
Sure.
Just look at them.
So is this um,
something that you played with a pc or
is this an okay,
I know this one's on all of them.
This one,
I can't play xbox games.
Once you play with a mouse and a
keyboard that controllers just so wide.
They're supposed to be making an update
soon.
So you can do that.
Actually a mouse and keyboard on the
next box.
Oh well that's what they should be
taking.
So long to do that.
Lizard has said there is so bad ass ears
ago.
There's still a thing like an x box has
said recently they would allow people to
play,
I guess people on playstation network,
but Sony doesn't want to play friends
with them at Sachs.
Well see the thing about computers is
when you have a mouse and a keyboard,
you can just have so much more
precision.
Guys get really good.
And they also have like auto aiming.
It keeps you in the box when you're
using those.
They,
the Vicks,
they've made it a little bit better.
So there's a little hand controllers are
more accurate than they used be.
But man,
it ain't the same when you're,
when you have a mouse and keyboard,
like if you watch that guy google
fatality in the eye and fatality was a
number one.
This guy would hit people with a rail
gun in the middle of the air so often it
was almost like he was psychic crazy and
you'd watch him play and you watch
through his eyes and you realize how bad
you are at the game and that was part of
the reason why I got so addictive made
it to number one on that new game I was
talking about.
He did his twitch channel says right
here,
it's not a stream.
Listen play.
That's him.
He's a savage.
I met that kid in Vegas.
Very nice car.
He's not a kid anymore.
I'm sure he's in this deep in his
thirties now I think because it's a long
ass time ago that he was running quake
unless he was six.
There he is.
He's a dad.
He's got dad bod,
got a fucking golf shirt on.
It's dropped his kids off at their
fucking out people online.
I love it man.
If this is like such a better future
than I predicted when I was a kid,
like I never imagined that we would be
able to watch people play video games or
that,
that you could make a career out of
playing not just a career,
but make more in a month than lawyers
make any,
had some odd,
these people were all painting and
playing music and stuff.
All right,
we're going to do it and we're going to
also do a pool on it,
right.
It was set that shit.
We got plans,
techno hunt.
We did this techno hunt thing.
Have you seen the technol hunt game yet?
Only.
Are you?
You like posting on an install?
Yeah,
I want to.
I want to check it out there.
We have thing live.
There's 40,000
people watching and we're shooting
arrows at this screen and then it's been
downloaded like 300,000
times in the first 24 hours.
The ETA on this man,
like when are you going to fully turn
this into like a video gaming compound?
Because pretty close,
really exciting and on it.
We're closing in on,
but the tech doe hunting.
What's fascinating about that is you use
a regular bow,
so it's real.
It's like real world practice.
A compound Ba.
Yeah,
like a real compound bow.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to use a powerful
one.
Supposed to keep it down to 70 pounds.
You can't Jack it up.
Like mine is jacked up to 84 pounds.
But I tried to eat a four pound one that
it didn't break it.
So we'll see.
I'm excited man.
I love this compound.
It's crazy to ass.
Yeah,
I can't wait to see what you do with it.
It's like you're just barely growing it
right now,
right?
Like well,
any suggestions you have been and if you
want to do something here,
we could do anything.
You want this.
If you have an idea,
the,
I liked the video game idea,
man.
Let's do it.
The idea of having some kind of like
twitch laboratory here is pretty cool.
That's exciting.
Let's do it.
So you heard it folks,
Duncan trussell's in for the twitch
league.
Don Don,
I suck at these games.
My kids are going to get daddy come
home.
God,
Duncan Trussell,
ladies and gentleman,
you could follow him and his antics on
twitter or Instagram,
but you don't use facebook,
dude.
No,
no.
There you go.
Duncan trussell family hour,
one of the best podcasts in the world.
Thanks Jeff.
I recommend you listen to the one with
Dr Chris Ryan is a really good one.
The last one you guys do any other times
when I do my podcast,
man,
bro,
come on,
Bro.
Young Jamie,
go to young jamie.com
and get your round earth shale tee
shirts or they back do you haven't
restocked they're not restocking so
fast.
I got one for you,
but yet powerful shirts in stock right
there.
There's some,
a couple of those left.
Couple hoodies left.
Yeah,
they'd go quick.
They go quick.
All right folks,
we'll be back tomorrow with a fill
demars formerly of marine worlds and I'm
going to,
we're going to have some fun.
Bye Bye.
Okay.